Hello and welcome to our second drink of Launch Party Part 1. We did a great deep dive in this episode about that cold open where the little DVD logo bounces around the screen. Jenna, you got fantastic behind-the-scenes details from writer Jen Salada about it. Yes, and since our breakdown of this first went out, many of you have written and to tell us about your own bouncing DVD logo stories. this whole bit that Jen Salada wrote for the office really took off. For example, Ray S. wrote in to say that he was at a John Mayer concert, and before John went on stage, he did a riff on this exact bit, and the crowd went nuts when it hit the corner.
你好，欢迎收听《办公室》第一季“发布会”的第二期节目。我们在这一集中深入探讨了那个小DVD标志在屏幕上弹来弹去的开场。珍娜，你从编剧珍·萨拉达那里得到了关于这个片段非常棒的幕后细节。是的，自从我们对这一幕进行解析后，许多听众写信告诉我们他们自己关于DVD标志弹跳的故事。珍·萨拉达为《办公室》写的这个桥段真的火了。例如，雷·S写信说，他在一场约翰·梅尔的演唱会上，在约翰上台之前，他即兴表演了这个桥段，当标志撞到角落时，全场观众都疯狂了。
Yes, and so many folks wrote in about moments like that. Alicia M. wrote in to say, Did you all see the video of this happening at a stadium? It must have been a football or soccer game. The whole stadium was awaiting the little corner. boop, it was amazing and definitely inspired by the office. Alicia, I think I found the moment you're talking about. If it was the one at that West Point football game and everyone was watching and they went
是的，很多人写信提到了类似的时刻。艾丽西亚·M写信问，你们看到那个在体育场发生的视频了吗？那一定是一场橄榄球或足球比赛。整个体育场都在等待那个小角落。砰，太神奇了，绝对是受《办公室》的启发。艾丽西亚，我想我找到了你说的那个时刻。如果那是西点军校那场橄榄球赛，每个人都在看，然后他们
crazy, folks also said they saw this same moment at baseball games and other big sports events, but lady, people at home also latched onto this idea and started posting on social media platforms of themselves in their own living rooms, watching their TVs, waiting for the logo to hit the corner. And I want to share one from these folks. They posted a video of it. They titled it, Freak Out After DVD Player, Screen Saver Bubble
疯了，大家还说他们在棒球比赛和其他大型体育赛事中也看到了同样的时刻，但女士们，家里的人也迷上了这个点子，开始在社交媒体平台上发布他们自己在客厅里盯着电视，等待标志撞到角落的视频。我想分享其中一个。他们发布了一个视频，标题是“DVD播放器屏幕保护泡泡完美撞击角落后的疯狂”。
Hits Corner Perfectly. Listen to how excited they get. Yeah, it will. You have to have faith. Faith in the DVD player. Faith in Sanja. Okay, it's coming up. This is it.
听听他们有多兴奋。是的，它会撞到的。你得有信心。对DVD播放器的信心。对桑贾的信心。好了，快到了。就是现在。
This is it. Come on, baby. Come on. I did it. Yes! Yes! Isn't that hilarious? Like how excited everyone is in their living room.
就是现在。来吧，宝贝。来吧。我做到了。耶！耶！这不是很搞笑吗？大家在客厅里有多兴奋啊。
Now, imagine that at a stadium. Yes. And the roar from the crowd. Well, one of my favorite things is that Michael C wrote in to tell us about this Reddit thread that broke down the probability of a DVD logo hitting the corner. Oh, my gosh. So this Reddit thread, I guess, is called They Did the Math. It actually has a lot of great.
现在，想象一下在体育场里。是的。还有观众的欢呼声。嗯，我最喜欢的事情之一是迈克尔·C写信告诉我们关于那个Reddit帖子，它分析了DVD标志撞击角落的概率。天哪。所以这个Reddit帖子，我想，叫“他们算出了数学”。它实际上有很多很棒的
deep dives. But this particular, I guess, is it called a subreddit was called what are the odds of the DVD screensaver logo directly hitting the corner? And did they do the math? Yes, they did the math. They all agreed, well, first of all, they all agreed that the actual odds of the logo hitting a corner on any given frame are heavily influenced by the dimensions of the screen, the dimensions of the logo, the starting point of the logo, the step size of the logo's movement, and the X and Y dimensions, and the programmed behavior when the logo hits an edge or corner. Oh, no. There's a lot of variables here.
深度解析。但这个特定的，我想，这叫子版块，叫“DVD屏保标志直接撞击角落的几率是多少？”他们算出数学了吗？是的，他们算出来了。他们都同意，首先，他们都同意标志在任何给定帧撞击角落的实际几率受到屏幕尺寸、标志尺寸、标志起点、标志移动步长、X和Y维度，以及标志撞击边缘或角落时的编程行为的严重影响。哦，不。这里有很多变量。
But after much discussion, they, quote, did the math, and basically, they calculated the number of frames between every corner hit. They determined the odds of hitting the corner directly, which was one in 11,700. and then they determined the frame rate for the NTSC DVD player, which is 29.97 frames per second, all of this translates into, are you ready? Drum roll. Yeah. One corner hit every 6.5 minutes. Wow. So you have to wait six and a half minutes. Mm-hmm. I love that. I love this conversation that Jensalata kicked off just because of this cold open. I know. Well, I have a little candy bag alt thing to share with you. Okay. When we first re-watched this episode, I didn't go digging in there, but for the second drink, I did, and I wanted to share something.
但在经过大量讨论后，他们“算出了数学”，基本上，他们计算了每次角落撞击之间的帧数。他们确定了直接撞击角落的几率，是11700分之一。然后他们确定了NTSC DVD播放器的帧率，即每秒29.97帧，所有这些转化为，准备好了吗？击鼓声。是的。每6.5分钟撞击一次角落。哇。所以你得等六分半钟。嗯哼。我喜欢这个。我喜欢珍·萨拉达仅仅因为这个开场就引发的这段对话。我知道。好吧，我有一个小小的糖果袋备选内容要和你分享。好的。当我们第一次重看这一集时，我没有去深挖，但为了第二期节目，我做了，我想分享一些东西。
So in this Michael Scott talking head that was in the candy bag alts, Michael Scott is kind of going up to the party and there's like guest check-in list. And he imagines this whole conversation that he's going to have with the person checking him into the party. Okay. Here's what he had to say. Knock, knock. Who's there? Michael Scott. Michael Scott, who?
所以在糖果袋备选内容里的那个迈克尔·斯科特的访谈中，迈克尔·斯科特正走向派对，那里有一个客人签到名单。他想象着他将要和那个为他办理签到的人进行的整段对话。好的。这是他要说的。敲敲。谁在那？迈克尔·斯科特。迈克尔·斯科特谁？
Michael Scott, I'm on the list. Oh, I don't see you. double check. It's with two T's. Uh-huh, still can't find it. Let me talk to your manager or you're fired. I get in. He gets fired. He begs forgiveness. I ask him to spell it. He spells it right, but I thought there was no E, so he's out of luck. Can I say something? What? That sounds very Dwight Shrewdy to me. It does, right? Yes. Here's an alt for that. Ready? It's a little shorter. Again, Michael is at that guest check-in with the host. Knock-knock. Who's there? Michael Scott. Oh, Michael Scott, we've been waiting for you. How is your convertible seabring?
迈克尔·斯科特，我在名单上。哦，我没看到你。再查一遍。是两个T的那个。嗯哼，还是找不到。让我和你经理谈谈，否则你被解雇了。我进去了。他被解雇了。他请求原谅。我让他拼写。他拼对了，但我以为没有E，所以他运气不好。我能说点什么吗？什么？这听起来很像德怀特·舒鲁特。确实，对吧？是的。这里有一个备选方案。准备好了吗？短一点。同样，迈克尔在那个客人签到处和主持人在一起。敲敲。谁在那？迈克尔·斯科特。哦，迈克尔·斯科特，我们一直在等你。你的敞篷赛百灵怎么样？
Have a crab cake and a glow stick. Hey, everyone. It's Michael. Hey, Michael. Have you met Paris? Hey, Paris. Hey, Michael. How's it going? Good. How about you? Pretty good. Let's move this conversation to the dance floor. I can't tell you the rest. I like that. That sounds a little more Michael to me. Right? I thought so. Well, listen, everyone, before we go, I just wanted to mention that tomorrow is Giving Tuesday. And our media company, Ramble, does donations to various organizations each year. And I wanted to shout out our donations this year, just to give a little visibility to some foundations that we think are doing great work. You know, I was on the board of directors for Mary's List for several years, and I just know how helpful shoutouts like this can be.
吃个蟹饼，拿个荧光棒。嘿，大家好。我是迈克尔。嘿，迈克尔。你见过帕里斯吗？嘿，帕里斯。嘿，迈克尔。最近怎么样？很好。你呢？挺好的。我们把这段对话移到舞池去吧。剩下的我不能告诉你。我喜欢那个。那听起来更像迈克尔。对吧？我也这么认为。好吧，听着，大家，在我们走之前，我只想提一下明天是“捐赠星期二”。我们的媒体公司Ramble每年都会向各种组织捐款。我想大声感谢我们今年的捐款，只是为了让一些我们认为在做伟大工作的基金会获得一点关注。你知道，我曾担任“玛丽名单”董事会成员好几年，我非常清楚像这样的宣传有多么有帮助。
In fact, Mary's List is a great organization. We've donated to them before. But this year, we are giving to Black Girls Code, AMSCI, World Central Kitchen, and Ronald McDonald's House. Yes, and I will put links to these places in our stories in case you want to find out more about them. And if you are doing any giving this Tuesday, I wanted to share another little thing that I learned doing my foundation work, which is that organizations really appreciate a small monthly donation. Like a one-time donation is wonderful, but if you break up that amount into 12 monthly gifts, it really helps the foundation budget they're giving for the year. And when they're filling out grant requests, it helps them to have a sort of subscription-based and they can plan more of their outreach in advance.
事实上，“玛丽名单”是一个很棒的组织。我们以前给他们捐过款。但今年，我们捐给了“黑人女孩编程”、AMSCI、世界中央厨房和罗纳德·麦当劳之家。是的，我会把这些地方的链接放在我们的故事里，以防你想了解更多关于它们的信息。如果你这个星期二有任何捐赠计划，我想分享我在做基金会工作时学到的另一件小事，那就是组织非常感谢小额的月度捐款。一次性捐款当然很好，但如果你把那笔钱分成12个月的礼物，这对基金会当年的预算非常有帮助。当他们填写拨款申请时，这种订阅式的捐款能帮助他们提前规划更多的外联活动。
So just throwing that out there in my personal giving, I do monthly donations now. That makes sense. Then they can budget how to best use that money. Yes. Yeah. All right. Well, everyone, now here is. our second drink of launch party part one.
所以我只是提一下，在我个人的捐赠中，我现在做月度捐款。这很有道理。这样他们就能预算如何最好地利用这笔钱。是的。好吧。那么，大家，现在是我们的“发布会”第一部分第二期节目。
I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories
我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供独家的幕后故事，
that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. It's party time, everybody. It's a launch party. Or is it a lunch party? How dare you? Is it a lanch party? Get out.
只有两个亲历者才能告诉你。我们是办公室女士。派对时间到了，各位。这是一个发布会。还是午餐会？你竟敢？这是一个“兰奇”派对吗？滚出去。
You and Kevin can get out. That is one of my favorite jokes, Lanch party. Yeah. Would that be better, Kevin? Would that be better for it to say lunch party? Well, it is a launch party. It is another one hour episode.
你和凯文可以滚出去。这是我最喜欢的笑话之一，“兰奇”派对。是的。那样会更好吗，凯文？说午餐会会更好吗？好吧，这是一个发布会。这是另一个一小时的剧集。
So you know what that means. We're doing launch party part one today. This was Season 4 episode. Episode 5, written by Jen Salata and directed by Ken Whittingham. I mean, one of our favorite duos. Oh, yeah. And this was actually Ken's sixth episode that he directed. We love Ken so much.
所以你知道这意味着什么。我们今天要做“发布会”第一部分。这是第四季的剧集。第五集，由珍·萨拉达编剧，肯·惠廷汉姆执导。我的意思是，我们最喜欢的二人组之一。哦，是的。这实际上是肯执导的第六集。我们非常爱肯。
I want you guys to know if you watch the bloopers, you will see a few times Jen and Ken cracking up and they whipped the camera over on them and bust them. But they were just so fun on set, weren't they, Jenna? They were so, like, light and there for you. and ready to laugh. I loved the two of them together. Same. All right, ladies, should I hit you up with a summary? Well, yeah, we got a lot to cover, so let's go.
我想让你们知道，如果你看花絮，你会看到几次珍和肯笑场，他们把摄像机转向他们并抓拍。但他们在片场真的很有趣，不是吗，珍娜？他们非常轻松，就在那里支持你，随时准备大笑。我喜欢他们两个在一起。我也是。好吧，女士们，我给你们总结一下？好吧，是的，我们要讲的内容很多，所以开始吧。
Well, here's what we're going to talk about this week. On the day of the Dunder Mifflin Infinity website launch, Dwight makes it his goal to beat the website and sales to impress Angela. Jim and Pam prank Dwight into thinking the computer is communicating with him, and Michael thinks he got invited to the fancy lunch. launch party with sushi in New York, but he is embarrassed to learn he was only invited to attend virtually. Yeah, he was invited to a chat room, which he thought was a club that had a secret password.
好吧，这就是我们这周要谈的内容。在邓德·米夫林无限网站发布当天，德怀特的目标是打败网站的销售额以打动安吉拉。吉姆和帕姆恶作剧让德怀特以为电脑在和他交流，而迈克尔以为他被邀请参加在纽约举行的豪华发布会，但他尴尬地发现他只是被邀请虚拟参加。是的，他被邀请进了一个聊天室，他以为那是一个有秘密密码的俱乐部。
Exactly. The password is password. Yeah. Is there a WWW before that club name? Well, listen, this episode also features a very. famous cold open from the series. You know the one I'm talking about, Angela. I do. I love it. And Jenna, I have had people right in and tell me that they do this in their office now. Yes. That it sort of started a thing. When I watched this episode with Lee, he said, I've done this. I've done this.
没错。密码就是“密码”。是的。那个俱乐部名字前面有WWW吗？好吧，听着，这一集还有一个非常著名的系列开场。你知道我在说什么，安吉拉。我知道。我喜欢它。珍娜，我有人写信告诉我他们现在在办公室里也这么做。是的。它似乎开启了一种风潮。当我和李看这一集时，他说，我做过这个。我做过这个。
So it's the one that takes place in the conference room and everyone's watching this little DVD square on the screen behind Michael as he is. trying to lecture us about, I don't know what, ideas to improve? Quarterly, yeah. He's trying to tell us how to improve or spruce up the quarterlies, right? They're boring. Very boring. Well, we thought that today, in lieu of fast facts, we should do a deep dive on this cold open. We should, you guys, because there's some fun, fun info for you.
所以这就是发生在会议室里的那一幕，每个人都在盯着迈克尔身后的那个小DVD方块，当时他正试图向我们讲授，我不知道是什么，改进建议？季度报告，是的。他正试图告诉我们如何改进或美化季度报告，对吧？它们很无聊。非常无聊。好吧，我们认为今天，代替快速事实，我们应该对这个开场进行深度解析。我们应该这样做，伙计们，因为有一些非常有趣的资讯给你们。
So we reached out to her writer, Jen Salada, because we heard a rumor that this might have happened to her in her real life. It was somehow based on her, right, Jenna? Yes. And she had some great stuff to say. So let's do a deep dive with this cold open. Cold open deep dive, Sam. Will you play my son's sting?
所以我们联系了编剧珍·萨拉达，因为我们听到一个传言，这可能在她的现实生活中发生过。它在某种程度上是基于她的，对吧，珍娜？是的。她有一些很棒的话要说。所以让我们对这个开场进行深度解析。开场深度解析，萨姆。你能播放我的主题曲吗？
You got a deep, you got to dive. You put them together. Get it deep dive. There it is. There it is. All right. So like we said, Michael's having a meeting and behind him is this TV screen. And you don't really know what's going on at first because it just keeps.
你有一个深度，你有一个解析。你把它们放在一起。明白了吗，深度解析。就是这样。就是这样。好吧。所以就像我们说的，迈克尔正在开会，他身后是那个电视屏幕。起初你真的不知道发生了什么，因为它只是不断地
panning around to everyone in the conference room, and we are oddly riveted by what Michael is saying. Yeah. And what he's saying is so boring. Like he's saying, I want to make suggestions to spruce up these quarterly reports. He's saying things like, what if in a bad quarter, there's a storm cloud, or in a good quarter, there's fireworks, or a race car. And then we all go, ugh. And he goes, not a race car. It doesn't have to be a race car. So then we go to this gym talking head, and he explains what's going on. He says that they are all wanting to see if this little DVD cube on the TV screen will hit perfectly in the corner. And he says he doesn't think it can happen and that Pam claims she saw once when she was alone in the conference room. And then, Jenna, it cuts to your talking head.
在会议室里的每个人身上扫过，而我们对迈克尔说的话感到奇怪地着迷。是的。他说的内容太无聊了。就像他说，我想提出建议来美化这些季度报告。他说诸如，如果季度表现不好，有一个风暴云，或者表现好，有烟花，或者赛车。然后我们都说，呃。他说，不是赛车。不一定要是赛车。然后我们转到吉姆的访谈，他解释了发生了什么。他说他们都想看看电视屏幕上的那个小DVD方块是否会完美地撞击到角落。他说他不认为这会发生，帕姆声称她有一次独自在会议室时看到过。然后，珍娜，切到了你的访谈。
And you're so cute in this. You're like, I did see it. Did Jim say I didn't see it? It's very cute. It seems like we get to see a little joke between Jim and Pam. Yes. So then the boring meeting continues. And then finally, it happens.
你在这一幕里太可爱了。你说，我确实看到了。吉姆说我没看到吗？非常可爱。看起来我们看到了吉姆和帕姆之间的一个小玩笑。是的。然后无聊的会议继续。最后，它发生了。
The little cube goes in the square and everybody cheers. And Michael thinks that it is because he has said something brilliant. Yeah, his whole Where's Waldo thing was a big hit. And he's so happy. Michael is like, hey, some days you just got it. Yeah, some days you're just on fire. Yeah. Well, I remember shooting this, Angela.
小方块进入了角落，每个人都欢呼起来。迈克尔以为这是因为他说了什么绝妙的话。是的，他的“沃尔多在哪里”之类的东西大受欢迎。他太高兴了。迈克尔就像，嘿，有些日子你就是状态很好。是的，有些日子你就是火力全开。是的。好吧，我记得拍摄这一幕，安吉拉。
It was so much fun. But it was also like something we had to choreograph. Do you remember? I do. And, guys, it is true that this cold. open was based on a real-life experience of Jen Salada in the writer's room. And it was the inspiration for her writing this little cold open. We asked her about it. And here's what she had to say. So the inspiration for the cold open where the DVD logo bounces around the TV screen and
太有趣了。但这就像我们需要编排的东西。你记得吗？我记得。而且，伙计们，这个开场确实是基于珍·萨拉达在编剧室的真实经历。这就是她写这个小开场的灵感来源。我们问了她。这是她要说的。所以，DVD标志在电视屏幕上弹来弹去，
everybody's transfixed was definitely the writer's room. I was obsessed with it. We would all watch the little DVD logo. And I remember that I saw it. once hit perfectly in the corner that the edge of the logo lined up with the edge of the TV and it just felt so good. And I remember there was at least one non-believer in the room and it would hit like kind of close to the corner and they'd say that was it. That must be what you remember. It's not going to hit perfectly in the corner. And so I was transfixed with the logo and watching it a lot of the time and maybe not paying attention as much as I should have. to the task at hand.
每个人都目不转睛的开场灵感，绝对来自编剧室。我当时对它着迷了。我们都会盯着那个小DVD标志。我记得我曾经看到它完美地撞击到角落，标志的边缘与电视的边缘对齐，那种感觉太棒了。我记得房间里至少有一个怀疑论者，它会撞到离角落很近的地方，他们会说，就是那个了。那一定是你记得的那个。它不会完美地撞击到角落。所以我被那个标志迷住了，大部分时间都在盯着它看，可能没有像我应该做的那样关注手头的工作。
So that is where the inspiration for it came from. So basically, Jen was Pam. Yes, Jen was Pam and no one believed her. And she was adamant about it. And she wanted everyone else to see it go in the corner to, like, affirm her. This is what I love about Jen. If you guys have noticed, you've been listening to our podcast. Her episodes are so personal to her life experience.
所以这就是灵感的来源。所以基本上，珍就是帕姆。是的，珍就是帕姆，没人相信她。她对此非常坚持。她想让其他人看到它撞进角落，就像，肯定她一样。这就是我喜欢珍的地方。如果你们注意到了，你们一直在听我们的播客。她的剧集非常贴近她的人生经历。
Yeah. I mean, the WebMD thing, remember that she wrote about? And then now this, and there's always these little moments from Jen's actual life. And I think it is such a nice touch. And there are always these really ordinary moments that might otherwise pass you by. And something in her brain makes note of these. And that is why when you watch this cold open, it is so deeply relatable. It really is.
是的。我的意思是，WebMD那件事，记得她写的吗？现在又是这个，总是会有这些来自珍真实生活的小瞬间。我认为这是一个非常好的点缀。总是有这些非常平凡的时刻，否则你可能会错过。她大脑中的某些东西记下了这些。这就是为什么当你观看这个开场时，它是如此深刻地引起共鸣。确实如此。
I mean, Jenna, you and I both tempt. We sat through boring meetings all the time. And Jenna, you do this. You find little hooks. of something happening to get you through it. And it's like sometimes nothing you even, like, speak about with your other coworkers. You just all, like, lock on to something. I tipped at this office and all the executive side of the building face like a nice view of
我的意思是，珍娜，你和我都有过。我们一直坐在无聊的会议中。珍娜，你做这个。你找到一些小钩子，一些正在发生的事情来帮你度过难关。就像有时甚至不是你和同事谈论的事情。你们只是都锁定在某件事上。我在这个办公室实习时，大楼的行政一侧面向一个不错的城市景观，
the city, but everyone in cubicles faced a parking garage. Okay. Okay. This parking garage became our entertainment. Like, every day, I'd be like, well, it's happening in the parking garage. And they'd be like, oh, you remember blue zippy guy? You know blue zippy guy. He always zips around in that blue Toyota.
但隔间里的每个人都面对着一个停车场。好吧。好吧。这个停车场成了我们的娱乐。就像，每天，我都会说，好吧，停车场里正在发生什么。他们会说，哦，你记得蓝色拉风男吗？你知道蓝色拉风男。他总是开着那辆蓝色丰田车到处乱窜。
Oh, yeah, blue zippy guy got a new car. What? No. Yeah. And then one day, oh my gosh, it was like it ate up our whole day. There was a couple that would meet in the parking lot at lunch. Lady, I shit you not. It was like their meetup place.
哦，是的，蓝色拉风男换了辆新车。什么？不。是的。然后有一天，天哪，这简直占据了我们的一整天。有一对情侣会在午餐时在停车场见面。女士，我没骗你。那就像他们的见面地点。
What? And yes, they would pull up in two cars and we'd be like, uh-oh, they're here, they're here. And then they would get in one car and they would talk. Sometimes they would kiss. Nothing more than just like a smooch or two, but we became so invested in the parking lot couple. They were having an affair. That must have been an affair. Why would you meet up in a parking garage and in two separate cars and then get into one car and like smooch and stuff?
什么？是的，他们会开两辆车过来，我们会说，哦哦，他们来了，他们来了。然后他们会进到一辆车里，他们会聊天。有时他们会接吻。除了接吻一两次之外没什么别的，但我们对停车场情侣投入了太多感情。他们一定是在搞婚外情。那一定是在搞婚外情。为什么你要在停车场见面，开两辆不同的车，然后进到一辆车里，像接吻之类的？
If you're not like sneaking around, that is not normal. I guess you're right. Unless it's like their lunch breakers. something. I don't know. That's what I, it was around lunch and sometimes they would eat lunch together. So I thought, well, maybe there are a couple. Oh, well, then maybe there are a couple. I don't know. But also, maybe it was I don't know. But one day they got in a fight. Oh. We didn't know what it was about. We saw like sort of like hand, like, you know, you can tell body energy in the car. And then he got out and he slammed the door. And he kind of like leaned back on the back. I'm telling you, this is all we could think about. We couldn't think about any of the like work we were supposed to be doing. We're like, oh, he is piss. Have you seen? He's leaning up on the back of the car. Have you seen him? Oh, there goes blue zippy guy. That couple, that parking garage was your DVD square. Yes. Yes. But this is what I love about Jen is these little tiny moments that are so relatable when you work in an office all day. You have to find little things to get you through. Absolutely. Well, Angela, you mentioned that when we were shooting this, it was really technical. And we got a lot of fan questions about it. it. Oh, let's hear him. All right. Sandy P., Megan S., Miranda D., Mo Downey, and Amanda McKnight,
如果你不是在偷偷摸摸，那是不正常的。我想你是对的。除非那是他们的午休时间之类的。我不知道。这就是我，那是午餐时间，有时他们会一起吃午饭。所以我以为，好吧，也许他们是一对。哦，好吧，那也许他们是一对。我不知道。但还有，也许是，我不知道。但有一天他们吵架了。哦。我们不知道是为了什么。我们看到像手势，你知道，你可以看出车里的身体能量。然后他下车了，他砰地关上门。他有点靠在车后。我告诉你，这就是我们能想到的全部。我们无法思考任何我们应该做的像工作一样的事情。我们就像，哦，他气坏了。你看到了吗？他靠在车后。你看到他了吗？哦，蓝色拉风男走了。那对情侣，那个停车场就是你的DVD方块。是的。是的。但这正是珍让我喜欢的地方，这些在办公室工作一整天时非常容易引起共鸣的小瞬间。你必须找到一些小东西来帮你度过难关。绝对是。好吧，安吉拉，你提到我们拍摄这个的时候，它非常技术性。我们收到了很多粉丝关于它的问题。哦，让我们听听。好吧。桑迪·P、梅根·S、米兰达·D、莫·唐尼和阿曼达·麦克奈特，
all asked, how in the world did you time the cube to go in the corner at exactly the right moment? Did the show need to create like a special program for the DVD screensaver? You know, Ange, when I watched this, I have to say, I was kind of amazed. And I could not remember how we did it. I thought, did they make like a DVD disc and we had to time it all out? Yeah, I sort of remembered Ken Whittingham giving us cues. Did you remember that? Oh, like hand signals of when to cheer or when to be shocked or all of our reactions. Yeah, but I can't be sure.
都问，你们到底是怎么计时让方块在恰好正确的时刻进入角落的？节目组是否需要为DVD屏保创建一个特殊的程序？你知道，安吉，当我观看这一集时，我不得不说，我有点惊讶。我记不起我们是怎么做到的了。我想，他们是不是制作了一个DVD光盘，我们必须把时间都算好？是的，我有点记得肯·惠廷汉姆给我们提示。你记得吗？哦，比如什么时候欢呼或什么时候震惊或我们所有反应的手势。是的，但我不能确定。
I feel like Ken was giving us hand signals, but you know what? We asked Jen and she had a little something to say about it. So I couldn't remember how we actually feel. the DVD logo part of the scene. So I asked Dave Rogers, who edited the episode. And he said that we put the DVD screensaver in later. It was burned in later. So it was just a blue screen on the monitor while we were filming, which allowed us to play with the timing of when the logo would hit the edges of the TV. Yes. That makes so much sense. There was nothing on the TV. Nothing. And I think Ken was telling us like either like thumbs up to cheer or thumbs down.
我觉得肯当时在给我们打手势，但你知道吗？我们问了珍，她对此有一些话要说。所以我记不起我们实际上是怎么拍摄场景中DVD标志部分的。所以我问了剪辑这一集的戴夫·罗杰斯。他说我们后来才把DVD屏保放进去。它是后来烧录进去的。所以我们在拍摄时显示器上只是一个蓝屏，这让我们能够控制标志撞击电视边缘的时间。是的。这太有道理了。电视上什么都没有。什么都没有。而且我想肯当时在告诉我们，要么是竖起大拇指欢呼，要么是向下。
And we had certain words that Steve was going to say as Michael, right, that we knew. Well, I definitely remember that. I remember that Steve's dialogue was written. And this was unusual because a lot of times we would get in these conference room scenes and we could play around and we could improvise, but not with this because it was too important that we react off of certain things he said. Yeah. And we all had to react at the same time.
而且我们有一些史蒂夫作为迈克尔要说的特定台词，对吧，我们知道的。好吧，我绝对记得那个。我记得史蒂夫的台词是写好的。这很不寻常，因为很多时候我们会进入这些会议室场景，我们可以玩耍，可以即兴发挥，但这次不行，因为我们对他说出的某些话做出反应太重要了。是的。而且我们都必须在同一时间做出反应。
So it was very sort of like planned out. Well, we also asked Jen about writing this dialogue, and here's what she had to say. As far as dialogue for Steve in the cold open, I remember trying to match the dialogue with the reactions that everybody was having to the much more important DVD logo in the background. Steve always makes everything better. So it's possible that some of the dialogue was changed a bit or just making. better. But I remember when we were filming it, we also, with the camera that was on you guys, we had, you guys have various reactions so that we could just have them and Dave could edit them in, like just the crazy joy that you'd feel when it hit the corner and how frustrating it
所以它非常像计划好的。好吧，我们也问了珍关于编写这段对话的事，这是她要说的。至于史蒂夫在开场中的对话，我记得我试图将对话与每个人对背景中更重要的DVD标志的反应相匹配。史蒂夫总是让一切变得更好。所以有可能一些对话被稍微改动了，或者只是让它变得更好。但我记得当我们拍摄它时，我们也用拍摄你们的摄像机，让你们有各种反应，这样我们就可以拥有它们，戴夫可以把它们剪辑进去，比如当你撞到角落时感到的那种疯狂的喜悦，以及当它错过时会多么令人沮丧，这样我们就有了一堆反应可以玩，最后当戴夫试图组装场景时，我们可以把它们给他。我觉得它计时得太美妙了，捕捉到了方块撞击角落时的兴奋感。我非常喜欢史蒂夫如何演绎他认为一切都与他有关的事实，完全不知道在他身后发生了多么令人兴奋的事情。那真是太多的技术工作了。投入其中才实现了这一点。顺便说一句，珍给我们发了一张我们所有人的照片，从我们的
would be when it missed so that we had a bunch of reactions to play with that we could end up giving to Dave at the end when he was trying to assemble the scene. I thought it timed out so wonderfully and captured the excitement of when that cube hits the corner. And I just love so much how Steve plays the fact that he thinks that everything is about him, completely unbeknownst to him, the terribly exciting thing that's happening behind him. That is so much technical work. went into making this happen. And by the way, Jen sent us a picture of all of us from our
角度看着那个蓝色空白的电视屏幕。所以我们会把它发在播客里。是的，那太棒了。珍的小点子，这个发生在她身上的事情，最终成为了这个精彩的开场，真是太有趣了。这就是这一集开场的深度解析。我喜欢它。我也是。我自己也很享受学习所有关于它的事情，而且我当时就在那里。我觉得我们经常这么说。我们就像，哦，天哪，我们当时就在那里。那太酷了。
point of view looking at that blue blank TV screen. So we'll post that in the pod. Yeah, that is so great. And what a fun thing that Jen's little idea, this thing that happened to her, ended up being this fantastic cold open. And there is your deep dive of this episode's cold open. I loved it. I did too. I enjoyed learning all those things about it, my self and I was there. I feel like we say that a lot. We're like, oh my God, and we were there. And that is so cool.
而且我不知道那个。我重看节目时有时就是这种感觉。有时我就像，但我当时就在那里。我在那个房间里。那是我。我做了那个。我做了那个。没错。
And I didn't know that. That's how I feel when I rewatch the show sometimes. Sometimes I'm like, but I was there. I'm in that room. That's me. I did that. I did that. Exactly.
好吧。好吧，女士，我觉得我们应该去休息一下，然后回来进入这一集。我们来解析它。把它拆解，拆解。假期到了，这意味着这是用乐天省钱一年中最美妙的时光。
All right. Well, lady, I feel like we should go to break and then we'll come back and let's get into this episode. We'll break it. Bring it down, break it down. The holidays are here, and that means it's the most wonderful time of the year to save with Racketon.
使用乐天在您最喜欢的商店叠加现金返还，再加上假日促销。那是省上加省。有了乐天，您可以为您名单上的每个人购买礼物时获得现金返还，从给孩子的玩具到给热爱烹饪的人的厨房用具，再到给每个人的电子产品。
Use Racketon to stack cashback at your favorite stores on top of holiday sales. That's savings on savings. With Racketon, you can get cash back on gifts for everyone on your list, from toys for the kids to kitchen gear for the person who loves to cook. to electronics for everyone.
您甚至可以为自己省钱。只需在您喜爱的商店购物，现金返还就会自动添加到您的账户中，您可以选择通过Interact电子转账、PayPal或支票获得付款。今天免费加入，并在最低合格购买后获得新会员奖励。只需前往racketon.ca。下载应用程序或安装浏览器扩展程序。那是R-A-K-U-T-E-N。条款和条件适用。
You can even save on something for yourself. Just shop the stores you love and cashback is automatically added to your account and you can choose to get paid via Interact E-transfer, PayPal, or check. Join for free today and get a new member bonus after minimum qualifying purchases. Just go to racketon.ca. Download the app or install the browser extension. That's R-A-K-U-T-E-N. Terms and conditions apply.
本节目由BetterHelp赞助。所以我们到了。这是假期。假期是传统的时刻。我想当你想到假日传统时，你通常会想到，哦，我们怎么装饰？我们怎么交换礼物？但我不知道我们是否应该增加一些东西，一个假日的新传统，那就是自我保健的传统。哦，我喜欢那个。对吧？
This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. So here we are. It's the holidays. Holidays are a time of traditions. I think when you think of holiday tradition, you're usually thinking about, oh, how do we decorate? How do we exchange gifts? But I wonder if we should add something, a new tradition to the holidays, which is the tradition of self-care. Oh, I like that. Right?
是的。因为它可能是一个忙碌和混乱的时期。绝对是。而且它也可能是一个孤独的时期，你知道吗？是的。而且在假期优先考虑自我保健的传统，我觉得我们需要把它加到清单上。我真的很喜欢那个。好吧，你知道，你可能在假期期间不得不处理很多人的事情，而治疗
Yeah. Because it can be a hectic and chaotic time. Absolutely. And also it can be a lonely time, you know? Yes. And prioritizing the tradition of self-care at the holidays, I feel like we need to add that to the list. I really like that. Well, you know, you're probably having to deal with a lot of folks around the holidays, and therapy
可以是你学习积极应对技能、如何重置界限或只是设定界限并赋予自己力量成为最好的自己的一种方式。所以考虑在十二月尝试BetterHelp在线治疗，作为一种以清晰而不是混乱结束这一年的方式。这个十二月，通过照顾自己开启一个新的传统。我们的听众在betterhelp.com/office ladies可获得10%的折扣。那是better, h-e-l-p.com/office ladies。好的，我们回到发布会。珍娜，在我们进入这个之前，我只是想让你知道一件事。
can be a way for you to learn positive coping skills, how to reset your boundaries or just set your boundaries and empower yourself to be the best version of yourself. So consider trying better help online therapy in December as a way to close the year with clarity rather than chaos. This December, start a new tradition by taking care of you. Our listeners get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's better, h-e-l-p.com slash office ladies. Okay, we are back for a launch party. And Jenna, before we get into this, I just want you to know something.
我想我可能找到了你的灵魂伴侣。现在看，我知道你婚姻幸福。李，我道歉，但有些事情珍娜需要知道。珍娜，保罗·雷瑟，NBC情景喜剧《为你疯狂》的明星，可能是你的灵魂伴侣。你为什么这么说？他最近接受了AV俱乐部的采访，他说，我引用一下，好吧，我就是不看《权力的游戏》。哦，等等，还有更好的。他说，它不常出现。
I think I might have found your soulmate. Now look, I know you're happily married. And Lee, I apologize, but there's something Jenna needs to know. Jenna, Paul Reiser, star of NBC sitcom Matt About You, might be your soulmate. Why are you saying this? He did an interview with the AV club recently where he said, and I quote, well, I just won't watch Game of Thrones. Oh, wait, it gets better. He says, it doesn't come up that often.
没有人游说我去看它，但有些事情我已经了解到我就是不感兴趣。无论你多少次告诉我它很好，我都不能。准备好了吗？嗯哼。然后他继续说，就像去年，我和海伦·亨特一起上了吉米·法伦的节目。我没打算让这公开，但，你知道，他们问，你圣诞节打算做什么？海伦说，我要回家看新的《星球大战》电影。吉米说，你呢？
Nobody's lobbying for me to watch it, but there are certain things that I have learned that I just am not interested in. No matter how many times you tell me it's good, I can't. Are you ready? Uh-huh. Then he goes on to say, like last year, I went on Jimmy Fallon with Helen Hunt. And I didn't mean for this to be public, but, you know, they asked, what are you doing for Christmas? And Helen said, I'm going to go home and watch the new Star Wars movie. And Jimmy said, what about you?
我说，这是实话。哦，不。我从来没看过一部。观众倒吸一口凉气，就像我说我勒死了一只小狗一样。他说，我看过片段。我知道它们看起来像什么，但它不适合我。我不是在贬低它。它们显然非常好。
And I said, here's the truth. Oh, no. I've never seen one. And the audience gasped, like I had said, I strangled a puppy. He said, I've seen pieces. I know what they look like, but it's not for me. I'm not degrading it. They're clearly very good.
但我打算跳过它。哦，女士。天哪。这是你的灵魂伴侣。好的。我正在为自己组织一个晚宴。我要带上保罗·雷瑟，然后我得带上
But I'm going to skip it. Oh, lady. My God. This is your soulmate. Okay. I am forming a dinner party for myself. I'm going to bring Paul Reiser and then I got to bring
乔恩·费儒，因为我刚看他从零开始做酸面包。他当时……但乔恩·费儒正在做《曼达洛人》。他显然喜欢《星球大战》。哦，你是对的。这是一个糟糕的晚宴。这会……你想在晚餐时发生冲突吗？
John Favreau because I just watched to make some sourdough from scratch. He was... But John Favro is doing the Mandalorian. He clearly loves Star Wars. Oh, you're right. This is a horrible dinner party. This is going to... Do you want conflict at dinner?
天哪，你说得太对了。邀请我。我会做缓冲。好的。在你和乔恩·费儒之间。但我喜欢保罗·雷瑟说，我打算跳过它。天哪。
Oh my gosh, you're so right. Invite me. I'll be the buffer. Okay. Between you and John Favro. But I love that Paul Riser said, I'm going to skip it. Oh my gosh.
我读到那个时太开心了。我一直留着那个。我迫不及待想和你分享。我希望有一天我能遇到他，这样我们就可以讨论这个。我们属于一小群人，但外面还有更多我们这样的人。我收到过邮件。外面还有更多人只是对那个材料没有共鸣。天哪。
I got so tickled when I read that. I had, I've been saving that. I couldn't wait to share it with you. I hope that I run into him one day so that we can discuss this. We're part of a very small group of people, but there's more of us out there. I've gotten mail. There's more of us out there who just do not connect to that material. Oh, my gosh.
听到别人的声音非常有确认感。我刚给自己买了一件印有尤达宝宝的衬衫。看，我觉得尤达宝宝很可爱。我只是可能不想看一整部关于它的剧。但我知道。我会立刻把它挂在我的树上，你知道吗？好吧，尤达宝宝有了名字，每个人都在谈论它，但我知道你不在乎。
And it's very validating. to hear from others. I just bought myself a shirt with baby Yoda on it. See, I think Baby Yoda is very cute. I just maybe don't want to watch a whole show about it. But I know. I'll hang the ornament on my tree in a hot second, you know? Well, baby Yoda got a name and everyone's a buzz about it, but I know you don't care.
好吧，它叫什么？格罗古。G-R-O-G-U，格罗古。格罗古？格罗古是他的名字。好的。好的，保罗·雷瑟。我打算跳过它。
Well, what is it? Grow goo. G-R-O-G-U, grow-goo. Grogu? Grogoo is his name. Okay. Okay, Paul Reiser. I'm going to skip it.
你知道吗？那是一些严肃的PR能量。我打算跳过它。什么是PR？哦，保罗·雷瑟能量。你得看看。我只是喜欢他以“我打算跳过它”结尾。太美了。
You know what? That was some serious PR energy. I'm going to skip it. What's PR? Oh, Paul Reiser Energy. You had to look. I just love that he ends it with, I'm going to skip it. It's so beautiful.
太完美了。好吧，也许我们应该进入这一集。好的。我只是想让你知道我找到了你的灵魂伴侣。总之，让我们进入这一集。伙计们，这一集以一个精彩的场景开始。凯特·弗兰纳里和约翰·克拉辛斯基演得太棒了。我笑得太厉害了。
It's perfect. Well, maybe we should get into this episode. Okay. I just wanted you to know that I found your soulmate. Anyway, let's get to the episode. You guys, this episode starts with a fantastic scene. Kate Flannery and John Cresensky crushed this. I was laughing so hard.
一切都太好了。约翰的小瞬间太神奇了。所以梅雷迪思有点像在和吉姆调情。她说，嘿，谢谢你来医院看我。他说，好吧，等等，我们都来看你了。她说，是啊。然后她想让他给她的石膏签名，她拉起裙子，把骨盆靠向他。
It's all so good. John's tiny little moments are amazing. So Meredith kind of is like being flirty with Jim. She's like, hey, thanks for visiting me at the hospital. And he's like, well, wait, we all came to see you. And she's like, yeah. And then she wants him to sign her cast and she pulls up her skirt and leans her pelvis into him.
是的。吉姆说，好吧，没有别人签名。没有。她没有要求任何人签名。我知道。她想要一个签名，而且她想要在她回家时能看到的地方。哦，天哪。我有一个问题。
Yeah. And Jim is like, okay, no one else assigned it. No one. She doesn't ask anybody else to sign it. I know. She wanted one signature and she wanted it where she could see it when she gets home. Oh, Lord. I have a question.
好的。我们收到了很多关于这个场景的粉丝问题，但我先问我的问题。当你骨折时，你的骨盆上会打石膏吗？当你骨折时，那甚至是一回事吗？我应该查一下吗？我想我们应该查一下。我没想到要质疑它。但现在你提到了，它看起来像石膏内裤。
Okay. We got a lot of fan questions about this scene, but I'm going to start with my question. Do you get a cast on your pelvis when you break your pelvis when you break your pelvis Is that even a thing? Should I have looked it up? I guess we should have looked it up. I didn't think to question it. But now that you mention it, it looks like cast undies.
你怎么坐在那里面？你怎么上厕所？我有很多问题。好的。我们需要对骨盆石膏进行实时深度解析吗？我正在查。这是我正在输入的，关于你的骨盆。
How do you sit in that? How do you go to the bathroom? I had a lot of questions. Okay. Do we need a real-time deep dive on pelvic casts? I'm looking it up right now. Do you get a cast? This is what I'm typing in on your pelvis.
哦，天哪。会出来什么。你知道，我告诉你，安吉拉，因为这个播客，我有很多奇怪的搜索。哦，好吧，我知道。如果有人在调查我，他们会被我的搜索历史搞得非常非常困惑。我知道。我一直这么想。好的。所以这个医生说它就像肋骨。你不能给肋骨打石膏。根据罗斯伯格医生的说法，我们不给骨盆骨折打石膏。这是正确的吗，互联网。这就是罗斯伯格医生说的。好吧，科迪正在给我们发消息说她看到了同样的事情，你不能给骨盆打石膏。这类似于我的背部骨折。你不能打石膏。它就像肋骨骨折。好吧，那么继续
Oh, God. what's going to come up. You know, I'll tell you what, Angela, I have a lot of weird searches because of this podcast. Oh, well, I know that. If someone were investigating me, they would be very, very confused by my search history. I know. I think that all the time. Okay. So this doctor says it's like a rib. You can't cast ribs. We don't cast pelvic fractures, according to Dr. Rothberg. Is that correct, internet. That's what Dr. Rothberg says. Well, Cody is messaging us that she's seeing the same thing, that you cannot cast a pelvis. This was similar to my back fracture. You can't cast it. It's like a rib break. All right, well, moving
我们关于这个的粉丝问题。好的。汉娜·鲍姆加特纳、梅根·罗宾逊、米里亚姆·汉弗莱、米兰达·邓纳姆、艾莉森·埃利斯和许多其他人说，首先，他们为梅雷迪思制作了多少个石膏？约翰·克拉辛斯基在这个石膏上签的是他的真名吗？因为它看起来真的很像他写的是约翰·克拉辛斯基而不是吉姆·哈珀特。夏曼·马歇尔问，有人留着梅雷迪思的石膏吗？哦，我们知道所有这些的答案。我们联系了凯特·弗兰纳里，石膏内裤的穿着者。这是她要说的。凯特·弗兰纳里在这里澄清关于梅雷迪思骨盆石膏的任何谜团。第一个问题，他们有不止一个石膏吗？是的，我实际上不得不专门过来，我们做了大约八个石膏。我字面上
on to our fan questions on this one then. Okay. Hannah Baumgartner, Megan Robinson, Miriam Humphrey, Miranda Dunham, Alison Ellis, and many others said, first of all, how many casts did they make for Meredith? And did John Krasinski sign his real name on this cast? Because it really looks like he wrote John Krasinski instead of Jim Halpert. And Charmaine Marshall asked, did anyone keep Meredith's cast? Oh, we know the answers to all of that. We reached out to Kate Flannery, the wearer of the cast undies. And here's what she had to say. Kate Flannery here to clear up any mystery around Meredith's pelvis cast. First question, did they have more than one cast? Yes, I actually had to come in especially, and we did about eight casts. I literally
不得不躺在背上，穿着一条内裤在衣服外面，然后他们做了这些像石膏条的东西，用石膏粉弄湿，然后他们建造了它的前部。所以我有一个松紧腰带，我必须在它变硬之前把它拉下来。这就是她说的。我记得在MySpace上发过关于它的帖子，因为我有一个作为梅雷迪思的博客，我写了一整篇说梅雷迪思被石膏覆盖了。它自己就写出来了，不是吗？我确实记得拍了多次，尽管我们确实在第一次就拍到了，除了约翰不小心签了他的真名而不是吉姆·哈珀特的事实。而那个是我留下的。我仍然留着我的骨盆石膏。我用它做了一个咖啡桌。不，我不知道该拿它怎么办。
had to lie down on my back, wearing a pair of tidy whitties over my clothes, and then they did these like cast strips that they got wet with like plaster Paris, and they built the front of it. So I had an elastic waistband, and I had to pull it off before it got too hard. That's what she said. And I remember doing MySpace post about it because I had a blog as Meredith and I wrote a whole thing that said Meredith gets plastered. It just writes itself, doesn't it? I do remember doing multiple takes, although we did get it on the first one except for the fact that John accidentally signed his real name instead of Jim Halpert. And that is the one that I kept. I still have my pelvis cast. I made a coffee table out of it. No, I don't know what to do with it.
我不得不平躺着，在衣服外面穿上一条三角内裤，然后他们用浸过石膏粉的绷带条在我身上做了一个模具，把前身部分做出来。我当时穿着松紧腰带的裤子，必须在石膏变硬之前把它脱下来。她就是这么说的。我记得当时还在MySpace上发了帖子，因为我当时以梅雷迪思的身份写博客，我写了一整篇关于“梅雷迪思喝醉了”（Meredith gets plastered，注：plastered在英语中既有“打石膏”的意思，也有“喝醉”的俚语含义）的文章。这简直是浑然天成，对吧？我确实记得拍了好几次，尽管我们第一次就成功了，除了约翰不小心签了他的真名而不是吉姆·哈珀特的名字。而我保留的就是那一个。我至今还留着我的骨盆石膏模型。我把它做成了一张咖啡桌。不，我其实不知道该拿它怎么办。
my closet right now, but should I hang it on the wall? I don't know what to do. It's so good. Maybe it should be a coffee table. Maybe a Lusite box, like an art piece in the shrine that is the office in my house. Anyway, I hope I answered your questions. Bye. I vote for Lusite Box. I would so want that as a coffee table. I mean, it's a conversation starter. It really is. Well, you know, when Kate stopped by our little Zoom chat, she showed us. She held up the cast. And there it is. She's got it and John signed it. And if you're rewatching the episode at two minutes, 42 seconds, you can see John's signature plain as day. Well, I love knowing that that was the first take and that they used it anyway. They nailed it on the first take. Their
我现在的衣柜里，但我应该把它挂在墙上吗？我不知道该怎么办。它太棒了。也许它应该成为一张咖啡桌。也许是一个路西特盒子，就像我家办公室神龛里的一件艺术品。总之，希望我回答了你的问题。再见。我投路西特盒子一票。我真想把它当咖啡桌。我是说，它能开启话题。确实如此。嗯，你知道，当凯特顺道参加我们的Zoom小聊天时，她向我们展示了它。她举起了石膏模型。就在那儿。她拿到了，而且约翰签了名。如果你在两分42秒重看这一集，你可以清楚地看到约翰的签名。嗯，我很高兴知道那是第一遍拍摄，而且他们还是用了。他们第一遍就拍得很完美。他们的
performance was so good that when they got in the editing room, they were like, we don't care that he signed John Krasinski. We need this performance. It's too good. Yeah, I also think that was the first time, you know, because in rehearsal, Kate would not have lifted her skirt or any of that, right? Yeah. So that was the first time John is Jim, like, had to see all of it. And his reactions were so honest of like, oh, God, oh, she's lifting her skirt. Here we go. Well, we got another fan question, Angela, from Caitlin Oliver, who noticed Meredith is wearing a purplish eye shadow. Oh, yeah. She looks kind of cute today. Is this because she's back in the office or did she dress up specifically for Jim because she planned on hitting on him? Oh, I love to think she dressed up for Jim, but I noticed
表演太棒了，以至于当他们进入剪辑室时，他们说，我们不在乎他签的是约翰·卡拉辛斯基。我们需要这段表演。它太好了。是的，我也认为那是第一次，你知道，因为在排练时，凯特不会掀起她的裙子或做任何类似的事情，对吧？是的。所以那是约翰，也就是吉姆，第一次不得不看到这一切。他的反应非常真实，就像，哦，天哪，哦，她在掀裙子。我们要开始了。嗯，安吉拉，我们有另一个粉丝问题，来自凯特琳·奥利弗，她注意到梅雷迪思涂了紫色的眼影。哦，是的。她今天看起来挺可爱的。这是因为她回到了办公室，还是她特意为吉姆打扮，因为她打算勾引他？哦，我喜欢认为她是为吉姆打扮的，但我注意到了
that too. Her makeup had a little bit of a josh to it. Yeah, I noticed it as well. I like Caitlin's theory. I do too. Well, Caitlin, you'd probably love to know that at two minutes, 55 seconds, there is a fabulous shot of the plant at front reception. Tell me more. Well, there's a stripy pot. Stripey pot is back. Multicolored stripy pot. I remember it. So we are recycling pots. And this is a big leafy plant. We'll see how long it lasts. I need to reach out to, I don't know who it would be. Someone on Michael Gallenberg's team, I need to reach out to him and get more information on the plants. Who specifically some person on our crew was in charge of those plants each week. I need to know more. Yeah. Yeah. I would love that. Oh, my God. You know how happy I'd be to do a deep dive on Pam's plants. Get out. All right. This is my new mission. We're on it. We're on it. We're on it. We're on it. Well, also, I want to put something on your radar for this episode. We're going to track it. We're going to track the short jokes, Jenna. There's so many. There's so many. I was texting with Jen Salada last night about it. What up with the short jokes. We'll get to it. So, all right, Pam hands Michael a press release. It's a big day in this office, okay?
这一点。她的妆容确实有点特别。是的，我也注意到了。我喜欢凯特琳的理论。我也喜欢。嗯，凯特琳，你可能很想知道，在两分55秒，有一个前台植物的精彩镜头。多告诉我一些。嗯，有一个条纹花盆。条纹花盆回来了。五颜六色的条纹花盆。我记得它。所以我们在循环利用花盆。这是一株大叶植物。我们看看它能活多久。我需要联系，我不知道会是谁。迈克尔·加伦伯格团队里的某个人，我需要联系他并获取更多关于植物的信息。具体是谁，我们剧组里的某个人每周负责这些植物。我需要知道更多。是的。是的。我很乐意。哦，天哪。你知道我对深入研究帕姆的植物会有多开心吗。别开玩笑了。好吧。这是我的新任务。我们开始吧。我们开始吧。我们开始吧。我们开始吧。嗯，另外，我想让你关注这一集。我们要追踪它。我们要追踪那些关于身高的笑话，珍娜。太多了。太多了。我昨晚还在和简·萨拉达发短信讨论这件事。那些关于身高的笑话是怎么回事。我们会讲到的。所以，好吧，帕姆递给迈克尔一份新闻稿。这是办公室里的大日子，好吗？
Michael announces that he's going to New York to attend the party with all the important people. Yep. The non-important people are going to be at these satellite parties. And now we also find out that Dunder Mifflin Infinity, the website, will be launching. Yes. And there is a moment when Michael says, hey, I'm going to the fancy party. So if any of you guys have any good stories for me, you know, that I can talk about at the party, let me know. There is a shot of Creed.
迈克尔宣布他要去纽约参加有所有重要人物出席的派对。是的。不重要的人将参加这些卫星派对。现在我们还发现，邓德·米夫林无限公司，也就是那个网站，即将上线。是的。有一个时刻，迈克尔说，嘿，我要去那个高级派对。所以如果你们有任何好故事，你知道，我可以带去派对上讲的，告诉我。有一个克里德的镜头。
The camera zooms in and Creed's nodding like, yes, at like three minutes, 21 seconds. Yep. Jenna, this would have cut to a deleted scene where Creed goes in and pitches stories to Michael. No. Are you serious? I am serious. And he talks about like a guy with a bird and then someone jumps in the river. And Michael's like, this is a great story.
摄像机拉近，克里德在点头，就像，是的，在大约三分21秒。是的。珍娜，这本该剪辑到一个删除的场景，克里德进去向迈克尔推销故事。不。你是认真的吗？我是认真的。他讲了一个关于一个带鸟的人的故事，然后有人跳进了河里。迈克尔说，这是一个很棒的故事。
And Creed's like, oh, no, no, no, you can never tell this. Oh, no. But Creed had some fun stuff in this episode that's in the deleted scenes. Oh, that's so good. I know. And then we have this great talking head by Michael where he says Dundermifflin Infinity is the brainchild of his brainchild, Ryan. So therefore, this whole idea, Jenna, is Michael's brain grandchild. It is.
克里德说，哦，不，不，不，你永远不能讲这个。哦，不。但克里德在这一集里确实有一些有趣的片段，在删除的场景里。哦，那太棒了。我知道。然后我们有迈克尔的一段精彩采访，他说邓德·米夫林无限公司是他心血结晶的结晶，瑞安。所以因此，珍娜，整个想法是迈克尔的脑孙。确实是。
And he's so proud of it. He's so proud of it. I mean, he basically did it. Yeah. if you really think about it. Yeah. Well, as Michael is continuing to share with the group, he mentions that Dunder Mifflin is expecting record high sales and that they are anticipating that the website will become the new best salesman
他为此感到非常自豪。他为此感到非常自豪。我是说，他基本上做到了。是的。如果你真的仔细想想。是的。嗯，当迈克尔继续与大家分享时，他提到邓德·米夫林预计销售额将创历史新高，他们预计该网站将成为新的最佳推销员
at the company. Well, this really bumps Dwight. Yeah. Dwight does not want to be beaten by a website. So Dwight is going to challenge the website to a sales competition. Jen. And he's like trying to impress Angela. She's like, it's a waste of time. Oh, shorty joke, number one. Angel's like, it's a waste of time. Michael says, what's that pipsqueak? There it is, number one. Mm-hmm. So Jen Salada was saying she doesn't think she wrote any of these high jokes.
在公司。嗯，这真的让德怀特很不爽。是的。德怀特不想被一个网站打败。所以德怀特要向网站发起销售竞赛。珍娜。他试图给安吉拉留下深刻印象。她说，这是浪费时间。哦，矮子笑话，第一号。安吉拉说，这是浪费时间。迈克尔说，那个小矮子说什么？就是它，第一号。嗯哼。所以简·萨拉达说她认为她没写任何这些关于身高的笑话。
And I told her that Steve used to love as Michael to like comment on my size. Yeah. And I know, in fact, the next one we're going to talk about was improvised. But yes, I also loved the. in this scene, Jenna, that as Michael's reading the memo, Kelly's like, did Ryan mention if he's in a relationship? Yes, is that in the memo? Does the memo say anything about if he's in a relationship?
我告诉她，史蒂夫过去很喜欢以迈克尔的身份评论我的身材。是的。而且我知道，事实上，我们要谈论的下一个是即兴发挥的。但是是的，我也喜欢这一幕，珍娜，当迈克尔在读备忘录时，凯利说，瑞安有没有提到他是否在恋爱？是的，备忘录里有吗？备忘录里有没有说他是否在恋爱？
The corporate memo. Yeah. Well, we had a fan question about this scene from Chris Martens and Wyatt Hensley. They said, Dwight has a beard. Is that Rain's real facial hair? And
公司备忘录。嗯，我们有一个关于这一幕的粉丝问题，来自克里斯·马滕斯和怀亚特·亨斯利。他们说，德怀特留了胡子。那是雷恩真实的胡子吗？而且
how long was the break between mean episodes for him to grow this facial hair. They also want to know, is the unshaven facial hair supposed to show how distraught Dwight is without Angela? Well, I can tell you that the stubble was totally thought out. It was a plot point that Dwight is really distraught from his breakup, and he's kind of let himself go. And there was a talking head that would have supported this. There's a talking head at the beginning of the day, Dwight comes in, and Jim kind of takes a double take at him. And he's like, what's up with the stubble? And he's like, Friday, you left nothing. Monday, you have stubble. So now we know this episode's on a Monday, right? But Dwight just
两集之间有多长的休息时间让他长出这些胡子。他们还想知道，没刮的胡子是不是为了表现德怀特没有安吉拉有多痛苦。嗯，我可以告诉你，胡茬是完全经过深思熟虑的。这是一个情节要点，德怀特因为分手而非常痛苦，他有点自暴自弃了。有一个采访本来可以支持这一点。在一天开始时有一个采访，德怀特走进来，吉姆有点多看了他一眼。他说，胡茬是怎么回事？他说，周五，你什么都没有。周一，你有胡茬。所以现在我们知道这一集是在周一，对吧？但德怀特只是
looks at him and goes, I'm a man, Jim. And he's like, okay. All right, buddy. And then Dwight has a whole talking head. And he says, yeah, I stopped shaving because my girlfriend broke up with me. And he talks about how he's in pain. And it's comedic. But basically, he's, He's saying, my girlfriend broke up with me and it sucks. Yeah. So it was scripted that he would have this facial stubble, but that part got cut out. So then sort of leaves you wondering. But guys, in answer to the other question, there was just like in this deleted scene,
看着他说，我是个男人，吉姆。他说，好吧。好吧，伙计。然后德怀特有一个完整的采访。他说，是的，我停止刮胡子是因为我女朋友和我分手了。他谈到他有多痛苦。这很滑稽。但基本上，他是在说，我女朋友和我分手了，这太糟糕了。是的。所以剧本里写了他会有这些胡茬，但那部分被剪掉了。所以这让你有点好奇。但是伙计们，回答另一个问题，就像在这个删除的场景里一样，
a standard weekend break. So we would shoot Monday through Friday and Rain just had the weekend to grow this stubble. It's his real facial hair. The thing, though, that gets difficult is matching it every day throughout the week. So on Monday, he came in with this stubble, but then they would have to match that exact length on Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday, and Friday. So they would have to buzz it a little bit in hair and makeup. But listen, guys, I have worked with men who have to shave twice a day when they're shooting because our shoot days are so long. If they have a clean shaven look, by 4 o'clock, they get a little bit of a shadow and they send them back in to wash their face and shave with a razor so that we can keep shooting into the night and they match.
一个标准的周末休息。所以我们周一到周五拍摄，雷恩只有周末的时间来长出这些胡茬。这是他真实的胡子。不过，困难的是每天都要保持一致。所以周一他带着胡茬进来，但他们必须在周二、周三、周四和周五匹配那个确切的长度。所以他们必须在发型和化妆部门稍微修剪一下。但是听着，伙计们，我曾与那些在拍摄时每天不得不刮两次胡子的男人一起工作，因为我们的拍摄时间太长了。如果他们看起来是刮得干干净净的，到4点钟，他们就会有一点胡茬，他们会让他们回去洗脸并用剃须刀刮胡子，这样我们就可以继续拍摄到深夜，而且他们看起来是一致的。
Oh, could you imagine if you had to shave your legs like halfway through the day? No. I'd be so bummed. Yeah. That's a lot of maintenance. It's a lot of maintenance. Those guys would come in the hair and makeup trailers in the morning and they would, first thing they would do is shave. They wouldn't even shave at home a lot of them because they wanted it to last as long as possible for the shoot day.
哦，你能想象如果你必须在一天中途刮腿毛吗？不。我会很沮丧的。是的。那需要很多维护。那需要很多维护。那些家伙早上会走进发型和化妆拖车，他们做的第一件事就是刮胡子。他们中的许多人甚至不在家里刮胡子，因为他们想让它在拍摄当天尽可能持久。
Well, then there's also the fellows that have a hard time growing a beard. My husband's one of those guys. Yeah. Yeah, and then I've seen in there where they have to put hair on their face if their character needs a beard. Yeah, they get faky hair. Faky hair. Well, moving on, back in the episode, Pam has this talking head where she's going to explain this tension between Dwight and Angela. She says Dwight Mercy killed Angela's cat and it's caused a lot of unpleasantness.
嗯，还有那些很难长出胡子的家伙。我丈夫就是其中之一。是的。是的，我见过他们不得不把头发贴在脸上，如果他们的角色需要胡子的话。是的，他们用假胡子。假胡子。嗯，继续，回到这一集，帕姆有一个采访，她要解释德怀特和安吉拉之间的紧张关系。她说德怀特仁慈地杀死了安吉拉的猫，这导致了很多不愉快。
Angela has been in this real foul mood. She has. He put her cat in the freezer. I'm not blaming her. I would be in a foul mood. I, by the way, this is setting up the runner between you and Phyllis in this episode. That is one of my favorite of all time. You know what I noticed in this talking head is that Pam has on that unicorn necklace again.
安吉拉一直心情很不好。确实如此。他把她的猫放进了冰箱。我不怪她。我也会心情不好的。顺便说一句，这为你和菲利斯在这一集里的冲突做了铺垫。那是我有史以来最喜欢的冲突之一。你知道我在这个采访中注意到了什么吗，帕姆又戴上了那个独角兽项链。
Oh, she switched from her butterfly to the unicorn. Yeah, she's the unicorn again. And Angela has a gold cap. That necklace. I noticed that and it's real cute. I know. I would wear it. I would wear it. Well, back in the bullpen, Stanley is dancing to the music on his new website and Phyllis is so tickled. And it's just a small moment, but these are the moments I absolutely love about our show. Yeah. Just these little glimpses into the different desk pods. I just love it. Well, then we go to corporate ang and we have a Ryan talking head. He is in this gorgeous.
哦，她从蝴蝶换成了独角兽。是的，她又是独角兽了。安吉拉有一个金色的盖子。那个项链。我注意到了，它真的很可爱。我知道。我会戴它的。我会戴它的。嗯，回到办公区，斯坦利正在随着他新网站上的音乐跳舞，菲利斯非常高兴。这只是一个小瞬间，但这些是我绝对喜欢我们节目的地方。是的。只是这些对不同办公桌区域的小瞥见。我就是喜欢。嗯，然后我们去公司，我们有一个瑞安的采访。他在这个华丽的
corner office in a skyscraper, feet up on the desk. And you know what? He wants you to know, yeah, he created a website. Yeah. He created it. No big whip. No big whip. He's not trying to reinvent the wheel, but he's taking it to the streets while keeping an eye on the streets, Wall Street. You know, paper buying just became fun. Yeah, boom. But then you hear a voice of someone who's like, told you not to do these interviews in my office. So first of all, it's like how many of these has he tried to do in this guy's office? It's not his office. Ryan is such like, oh my God, he's such a cheeseball. Well, and then the camera pans down and you see a name plate on the desk that says Thomas Dean. And we got a fan question about this from Miles Peterson. Does the name
摩天大楼里的转角办公室，脚放在桌子上。你知道吗？他想让你知道，是的，他创建了一个网站。是的。他创建了它。没什么大不了的。没什么大不了的。他不是想重新发明轮子，但他正在把它带到街头，同时关注着街头，华尔街。你知道，买纸变得有趣了。是的，砰。但随后你听到一个人的声音，他说，告诉过你不要在我的办公室做这些采访。所以首先，就像他在这个家伙的办公室里尝试做过多少次了？这不是他的办公室。瑞安真是，哦，天哪，他真是个俗气的人。嗯，然后摄像机向下平移，你看到桌子上有一个名牌，上面写着托马斯·迪恩。我们收到了一个关于这个的粉丝问题，来自迈尔斯·彼得森。这个名字
Thomas Dean have any significance? Yes, guys. Tom Dean was our Pete. and that nameplate was in Tom's honor. Okay, Jenna, I think the voice of Thomas Dean is our editor, Dean Holland. I think it is too. Right? Yes. I would have sworn he was in the room with me when I heard that. It's got to be him.
托马斯·迪恩有什么意义吗？是的，伙计们。汤姆·迪恩是我们的皮特。那个名牌是为了纪念汤姆。好吧，珍娜，我认为托马斯·迪恩的声音是我们的剪辑师，迪恩·霍兰德。我也认为是。对吧？是的。我敢发誓，当我听到那个声音时，他就在我房间里。一定是他是。
Yeah. I think you're right. Well, I want to take us now to the scene with Andy and Dwight. I love that Dwight has his little champion. That Andy is so rooting for him in this. He's gotten really into it. And he says to Dwight, you know what? You need, like, a noise or something for, like, when you make a good sale, right?
是的。我想你是对的。嗯，我现在想带大家去安迪和德怀特的场景。我喜欢德怀特有他的小拥护者。安迪在这一点上非常支持他。他真的很投入。他对德怀特说，你知道吗？你需要，比如，一个声音或者什么的，比如，当你完成一笔好交易时，对吧？
Yeah. He's got his dry erase board. It's Dwight against the computer. And now they're brainstorming. What's the noise that goes off whenever Dwight makes a sale, right? We think we need a noise. Yeah. Here's Andy's suggestion.
是的。他有他的干擦板。这是德怀特对阵电脑。现在他们正在集思广益。德怀特每次完成交易时发出的声音是什么，对吧？我们认为我们需要一个声音。是的。这是安迪的建议。
He could say, kudos. Job well done. A chime. A bell. And Jim is peppering in these little smart-ass comments. He's saying, how about zipping? do da a gong and dwight's like ignore him here's what we're going to do here are the keys to my car go out under a whole bunch of pelts amazing there's a bear horn get that and he does yeah he does
他可以说，做得好。干得漂亮。一个钟声。一个铃声。吉姆在插嘴这些小聪明话。他说，来个拉链声怎么样？一个锣声，德怀特说忽略他，我们要这样做，这是我车的钥匙，出去拿一堆毛皮。太棒了，有一个熊号角。拿到那个，他确实拿到了。
andy is going to blow a bear horn every time dwight makes a sail well now we go to a scene that I've been waiting for. Angela and Phyllis, they're unrolling a banner for the launch party. But Phyllis has printed a banner that says lunch party. Angela is furious.
安迪每次德怀特完成交易时都会吹响熊号角。嗯，现在我们进入一个我一直在等待的场景。安吉拉和菲利斯，她们正在为发布派对展开横幅。但菲利斯打印了一个横幅，上面写着午餐派对。安吉拉非常愤怒。
She is so pissed off. She actually looks at Phyllis and says, what is wrong with you? Oh, Angela is in rare form. She's in rare form. and there was a deleted scene that might give us a window about this.
她非常生气。她实际上看着菲利斯说，你有什么毛病？哦，安吉拉处于罕见的状态。她处于罕见的状态。有一个删除的场景可能让我们了解这一点。
First of all, we know the breakup, right? She's still mad about sprinkles. She's ticked off. Well, there's another layer to it. There's a talking head where she says, tonight, my party will be broadcast out to five other states,
首先，我们知道分手了，对吧？她还在为斯普林克尔斯生气。她很恼火。嗯，还有另一层含义。有一个采访，她说，今晚，我的派对将向其他五个州广播，
which means it will be compared to Denise Stim's party in Buffalo. Oh, my God. There is a party planning committee rival. Denise stems in Buffalo? Yeah. And Angela hates her. And they get their parties compared.
这意味着它将与丹尼斯·斯蒂姆斯在布法罗的派对进行比较。哦，天哪。有一个派对策划委员会的竞争对手。布法罗的丹尼斯·斯蒂姆斯？是的。安吉拉讨厌她。他们的派对会被比较。
What is the backstory between Angela and Denise? Oh, it goes on from there. She throws major shade at her. She's like, Denise, you know what? We can all defrost hors d'oeuvres in a microwave. All right. That's what she does every party. And also, Denise, you're not fooling anyone with those curls.
安吉拉和丹尼斯之间有什么背景故事？哦，还在继续。她对她进行了严重的抨击。她说，丹尼斯，你知道吗？我们都能在微波炉里解冻开胃菜。好吧。那是她每次派对都做的事。而且，丹尼斯，你那些卷发骗不了任何人。
We know you get a perm. Okay? Like it goes... Oh, my God. Denise Stimbs. So she's got her breakup. She has our cat in the freezer. Phyllis cannot handle one simple task, and her party will be compared to Denise Stimms.
我们知道你烫了发。好吗？就像它还在继续……哦，天哪。丹尼斯·斯蒂姆斯。所以她有她的分手。她有我们的猫在冰箱里。菲利斯连一件简单的事情都处理不好，她的派对还要和丹尼斯·斯蒂姆斯进行比较。
So Angela is not having it. The stakes are high for Angela. Yeah. Well, this cuts to a Phyllis talking head where she explains that basically she's going to keep her cool and she is going to try out some new tactics for dealing with Angela. She has printed out all of this advice on how to deal with difficult people. She actually says she Googled how to deal with difficult people. Well, you know what, Angie.
所以安吉拉受不了了。安吉拉的赌注很高。是的。嗯，这剪辑到一个菲利斯的采访，她解释说基本上她要保持冷静，她要尝试一些处理安吉拉的新策略。她打印了所有关于如何处理困难人群的建议。她实际上说她谷歌了如何处理困难人群。嗯，你知道吗，安吉。
What? Obviously, I had to Google how to deal with difficult people. I wondered if you would. What'd you find out? Well, what I found out is that a lot of the tactics that Phyllis uses in this episode are the advice for dealing with difficult people, asking the difficult person how they're feeling, like saying affirmative things, like, I could see why you might be upset, like things like that. Well, I'll tell you something.
什么？显然，我不得不谷歌如何处理困难人群。我想知道你会不会。你发现了什么？嗯，我发现菲利斯在这一集中使用的大部分策略都是处理困难人群的建议，询问困难的人他们感觉如何，比如肯定的话语，比如，我能看出你为什么会心烦，比如类似的事情。嗯，我告诉你一件事。
If someone had made a banner that said lunch party and then turned to me and said, how do you feel about the fact that the banner says lunch? Uh-huh. I would probably say, I feel like you're a dumbass. That's how I feel. Like, that is not something you say to someone who's already annoyed with you. So that cracked me up when Phyllis said that. I was like, if I was Angela, I would still be pissed off.
如果有人做了一个写着午餐派对的横幅，然后转过身对我说，你对横幅上写着午餐这个事实有什么感觉？嗯哼。我可能会说，我觉得你是个笨蛋。这就是我的感觉。就像，那不是你对一个已经对你感到恼火的人说的话。所以当菲利斯那样说时，我笑坏了。我想，如果我是安吉拉，我仍然会很生气。
That would not have helped my situation. And, you know, it's not helping Phyllis that Kevin is now involved in this discussion. And then Michael walks up and says, nobody cares about this party anyway, booster seat. Mm-hmm. Shorty joke number two. Shorty joke number two. and I want you to know that Steve improvised a whole bunch and I never knew what he was going to say
那对我的情况没有任何帮助。而且，你知道，凯文现在参与到这个讨论中对菲利斯也没有帮助。然后迈克尔走过来，说，反正没人关心这个派对，增高垫。嗯哼。矮子笑话第二号。矮子笑话第二号。而且我想让你知道，史蒂夫即兴发挥了很多，我从来不知道他会说什么
and there's bloopers of me cracking up but there you go Angela's ticked and no one is helping well this is when Angela has her talking head that I love so much when she says that she's been asked to plan a party with only a $65 budget and four idiots that are doing nothing
而且有我笑场的花絮，但就是这样，安吉拉很生气，没有人帮忙。嗯，这就是安吉拉进行我非常喜欢的采访的时候，她说她被要求策划一个只有65美元预算的派对，还有四个什么都不做
but weighing her down oh and her cat is still dead. Yeah. And the entire world will see it, including Denise Stims. Yeah. Well, listen, I think we should take a break because when we come back, Dwight is going to fuel up for his big competition against the computer. He's got to. He's got to refuel. Yeah, big day. All right. We'll see you in a sec. All right, we are back and like we said, Dwight is fueling up literally. He's squeezing some kind of power protein gunk in his mouth. Yeah, it's a power gel. Of course I had to look it up, Jenna.
只会拖她后腿的白痴。哦，而且她的猫还是死的。是的。全世界都会看到它，包括丹尼斯·斯蒂姆斯。是的。嗯，听着，我想我们应该休息一下，因为当我们回来时，德怀特将为他与电脑的大赛加油。他必须加油。他必须加油。是的，大日子。好吧。我们一会儿见。好吧，我们回来了，就像我们说的，德怀特正在加油，字面意思。他正在往嘴里挤某种能量蛋白糊。是的，那是能量胶。当然我不得不查一下，珍娜。
Oh, it's called power gel. Well, their power gels are energy gels, right? Okay, yep. And I looked them up. Here's what they are. They're like a liquid carbohydrate, and they're used by endurance athletes. to fuel their training. Like when you see guys running marathons or, you know, the triathletes
哦，它叫能量胶。嗯，他们的能量胶是能量凝胶，对吧？好的，嗯哼。我查了它们。这就是它们。它们就像一种液体碳水化合物，被耐力运动员使用。来为他们的训练加油。就像当你看到人们跑马拉松，或者，你知道，铁人三项运动员
or these people who do the whole like Tour de France, you know? Yeah. And they're squeezing these little tubes of things in their mouth. Uh-huh. That's what this is. But it's for high endurance athletes to like replenish everything that's been depleted from the running and cycling. Jenna, there's so much online about these.
或者这些参加环法自行车赛的人，你知道吗？是的。他们正在把这些小管子里的东西挤进嘴里。嗯哼。这就是这个。但它是为了让高耐力运动员补充跑步和骑行所消耗的一切。珍娜，网上有很多关于这些的东西。
Oh, my gosh. There are multiple YouTube videos about how to eat one. when to eat them? Are you supposed to eat them before doing the endurance activity while doing it or after? While doing it. Like when you get depleted, you know? Okay. And talk about your random history and your search engine.
哦，天哪。有多个YouTube视频关于如何吃一个。什么时候吃它们？你是应该在进行耐力活动之前吃，还是在进行过程中，还是之后？在进行过程中。就像当你消耗殆尽时，你知道吗？好的。谈谈你的随机历史和你的搜索引擎。
Yeah. Jenna, I was watching a video of these two guys cycling in England who were talking about their energy gels. I'm like, what am I doing watching these two guys in England? Oh my God. Also, there's a ton, a ton of like options for you. if you want energy gels, and I found one that I really feel like Dwight inspired. What is it?
是的。珍娜，我正在看两个在英国骑自行车的家伙的视频，他们在谈论他们的能量胶。我在想，我为什么要看这两个在英国的家伙？哦，天哪。另外，有很多，很多选择。如果你想要能量胶，我发现了一个我真的觉得德怀特启发了它的。是什么？
It's called Beat Elite. No! Yes, Beat Elite Energy Jill. You know, this is what Michael needed during Fun Run. Yes, not Fetuccini Alfredo. No. He needed a Beat Elite. Well, Dwight is being very annoying.
它叫Beat Elite。不！是的，Beat Elite能量胶。你知道，这就是迈克尔在趣味跑期间需要的。是的，不是意大利面。不。他需要一个Beat Elite。嗯，德怀特非常烦人。
He's annoying Jim. He throws his gel packet onto Jim. Jim's desk. Yeah. Jim has to get rid of it. So Jim goes up to Pam and says, do you want to pull a prank on Dwight because he's being super annoying? And Pam is, she's torn.
他很烦吉姆。他把他的胶水包扔在吉姆身上。吉姆的桌子上。是的。吉姆必须把它处理掉。所以吉姆走到帕姆身边说，你想对德怀特搞个恶作剧吗，因为他太烦人了？帕姆很纠结。
She's like, well, I mean, he's going through a breakup. But then the bear horn. Yeah. So then Dwight like fires off the bearhorn. It's really loud. And Pam's like, you know what? I'm in. What are we doing?
她说，嗯，我是说，他正在经历分手。但后来那个熊号角。是的。所以德怀特吹响了熊号角。声音真的很大。帕姆说，你知道吗？我加入。我们做什么？
So Jim hatches this plan where. they are going to direct message Dwight as the computer system. They're going to send him messages as if the computer has come alive. Yes. And you know, this is perfect for Dwight. Yeah. This is the perfect prank because, of course, Dwight would entertain this. So when Pam is typing to Dwight, these DMs,
所以吉姆制定了这个计划，他们要以电脑系统的身份直接给德怀特发信息。他们要给他发信息，就好像电脑活过来了一样。是的。你知道，这对德怀特来说是完美的。是的。这是完美的恶作剧，因为，当然，德怀特会配合这个。所以当帕姆给德怀特打字时，这些私信，
we had some fan questions from Amanda McKnight and Matthew Lister. when Pam's typing all of the instant messages, was it Jenna typing with her crazy good typing skills or was it the computer? Well, I'll tell you. It was both. So when they do these scenes where something specific has to show up
我们收到了一些粉丝问题，来自阿曼达·麦克奈特和马修·利斯特。当帕姆打所有即时信息时，是珍娜用她疯狂的打字技巧打的，还是电脑？嗯，我告诉你。两者都有。所以当他们做这些需要特定东西出现在电脑屏幕上的场景时，
on the computer screen, they've created a program where it doesn't matter what button you press on the keyboard, the words come up as they should. So you can't mess it up. It's actually, yeah. Yeah.
他们创建了一个程序，无论你在键盘上按什么键，文字都会按应有的方式出现。所以你不会搞砸。它实际上是，是的。是的。
You can hit any. key, you could hit the space bar five times. The sentence will type. Yes. And at the end of the scene, you hit escape and then you would usually hit like F1 and then it starts the program over again. So they're super fun to play with. It sort of takes you back to your childhood when you would want to pretend like you were doing something. I always love these little programs. But at the same time, I was personally compelled to type out the words correctly. But this caused a problem because it was too many strokes of the keyboard because each time I hit a key, it translated into more than one letter, right? So it would be like, in order to run this program, I would have to type 24
你可以按任何键。你可以按五次空格键。句子就会打出来。是的。在场景结束时，你按退出，然后你通常会按F1，然后它会重新开始程序。所以玩起来超级有趣。它有点把你带回童年，那时你会想假装你在做某事。我总是喜欢这些小程序。但与此同时，我个人被迫正确地打出这些词。但这导致了一个问题，因为键盘敲击次数太多了，因为每次我按一个键，它就翻译成不止一个字母，对吧？所以就像，为了运行这个程序，我必须打24
things, but to actually type the sentence, it would be more like 48. So I had to like really hold back. It was, it was tough for me. I know. I know it was. Yeah. Because your integrity as a typist, You're like, that's not correct. That is not how many keys you hit to spell the word hello. That's right. And I made my living as a transcriber for many years. I know. So I need to type what I hear.
个东西，但要真正打出这个句子，它更像是48个。所以我不得不真的克制自己。这，这对我来说很难。我知道。我知道是的。因为你作为打字员的正直，你会说，那是不对的。拼写hello这个词不需要按那么多键。没错。而且我作为转录员谋生了很多年。我知道。所以我需要打出我听到的。
It was real hard. Well, you did it. I did it. I got through it. You got through it. But it's a really cute runner for Jim and Pam. And it's making Dwight crazy. Well, he says in his talking head, sometimes.
这真的很难。嗯，你做到了。我做到了。我挺过来了。你挺过来了。但这对吉姆和帕姆来说是一个非常可爱的跑动。而且它让德怀特发疯。嗯，他在采访中说，有时
computers come to life. But he is not scared. It is the computer that should be scared because he has been salesmen 13 months out of the last 12 months. You heard him correctly. In February, instead of a raise, Dunder Mifflin awarded him two plaques. I really feel like Dunder Mifflin has overlooked Dwight. I agree. I mean, he is clearly the best salesman and has been for a long time, and he never gets upper management. And this is going to go on for years for him. Now, listen, he's salty. He's a salty character.
电脑会活过来。但他并不害怕。应该是电脑害怕，因为他在过去12个月里有13个月是销售冠军。你没听错。在二月，邓德·米夫林没有给他加薪，而是奖励了他两块牌匾。我真的觉得邓德·米夫林忽视了德怀特。我同意。我是说，他显然是最好的推销员，而且已经很久了，他从来没有进入高层管理。这对他说将持续多年。现在，听着，他很刻薄。他是一个刻薄的角色。
But I feel like Dunder Mifflin could do better by Dwight. There, I'll just, I said it. I'm glad you said it. Thank you. It needed to be said. Michael is now really needing the ladies and Oscar to weigh in on his outfit for the fancy party he's going to go to. This shirt is ridiculous. Ridiculous.
但我感觉邓德·米夫林可以对德怀特更好。好了，我说了。我很高兴你说了。谢谢。这是必须说的。迈克尔现在非常需要女士们和奥斯卡对他要去参加的高级派对的服装发表意见。这件衬衫太荒谬了。荒谬。
It's bright purple. It has like a sheen to it. Like light bounces off of it. And it is so, so tight. And Oscar has a great line. Oscar says, is this why I'm in here? And he just gets up and walks out. I know.
它是亮紫色的。它有一种光泽。就像光从上面反射出来一样。而且它非常，非常紧。奥斯卡有一句很棒的台词。奥斯卡说，这就是我在这里的原因吗？然后他直接站起来走开了。我知道。
And no one likes it. All the women are like, no, no, no. Also, Jeddah, did you notice how long it is? Very long. He insists that it's European cut, which is the same thing he said about the woman's suit. that he bought. Michael is very attracted to this idea of a European cut. He thinks that this is style. Yes. It could also be what you say when something doesn't fit you right. Like the next time
而且没人喜欢它。所有的女士都说，不，不，不。还有，珍娜，你注意到它有多长了吗？非常长。他坚持认为这是欧洲剪裁，这和他买的那套女式西装说的一样。迈克尔非常被欧洲剪裁这个想法所吸引。他认为这就是风格。是的。这也可能是当某件东西不合身时你会说的话。就像下次
I put on a pair of sweatpants that are like too long in the crotch or something, I'm going to say, oh, it's a European cut. European cut. Well, then Jan calls in the conference room. And it's clear that Michael is unsure about taking this call, but he does take the call. Yeah, he does not want to talk to her. And he takes the call. She does not want to go to the party. She doesn't want to go. But why?
我穿上一条裤裆太长的运动裤什么的，我会说，哦，这是欧洲剪裁。欧洲剪裁。嗯，然后简打来电话到会议室。很明显，迈克尔不确定是否要接这个电话，但他确实接了。是的，他不想和她说话。但他接了电话。她不想去派对。她不想去。但为什么？
All her friends will be there. She's like, Michael, I was fired. Yeah. She's like, they're not my friends. So Michael asks if he could bring Carol instead. She's like, what? And he's like, fine, I'll find someone I didn't sleep with. Yeah.
她所有的朋友都会在那里。她说，迈克尔，我被解雇了。是的。她说，他们不是我的朋友。所以迈克尔问他是否可以带卡罗尔去。她说，什么？他说，好吧，我会找一个我没睡过的人。是的。
But he doesn't want to go alone. That's the point. Well, there is a deleted scene. Michael and Jan go on to have even more conversation. And Jenna, it's all delicious. It is all amazing. If I could, I would have, like, asked them to leave it all in. I am telling you, she says, you know what I want to do?
但他不想一个人去。这就是重点。嗯，有一个删除的场景。迈克尔和简继续进行了更多的对话。而且珍娜，这一切都很美味。这一切都很棒。如果可以的话，我会，比如，要求他们把这一切都留下来。我告诉你，她说，你知道我想做什么吗？
I want to make a pot roast. Why don't we stay home? I'll make a pot roast. Oh, do you know what I did today? I went to Costco. I got some more Zen. Oh, and I bought a bike. guess how much the bike was?
我想做炖牛肉。我们为什么不待在家里？我会做炖牛肉。哦，你知道我今天做了什么吗？我去了Costco。我买了一些更多的禅。哦，我还买了一辆自行车。猜猜自行车多少钱？
And he's like, I don't know, $60? She goes, why would you say a bicycle was $60, Michael? Why would you say that? And he's like, I don't know. And she goes, it was $500, Michael. Oh, my God. It's just more of a window into their relationship. And I can't get enough of it.
他说，我不知道，60美元？她说，迈克尔，你为什么会说一辆自行车是60美元？你为什么会那样说？他说，我不知道。她说，那是500美元，迈克尔。哦，天哪。这只是对他们关系的更多了解。我怎么看都不够。
I can't get enough either. It's all so good. She bought a bike at Costco for 500 bucks. What is she doing all day? Wait, did she buy the bike at Costco or she went to Costco? She bought the bike at Costco. Oh, I see. Well, listen, the competition is on between Dwight and the website.
我也看不够。这一切都太好了。她在Costco花了500块钱买了一辆自行车。她整天在做什么？等等，她是去Costco买的自行车，还是她去了Costco？她在Costco买了自行车。哦，我明白了。嗯，听着，德怀特和网站之间的竞争开始了。
Dwight is not doing well. But in the meantime, Pam and Jim, they're in the break room, the flirt room. They're having a snack. 12 minutes, two seconds, baby carrot alert. John Krasinski's eating those baby carrots again. Oh. He's back on his side. healthy kick well yeah he's no more popcorn he's back to the carrots Michael walks in and says hey what are you
德怀特表现不好。但与此同时，帕姆和吉姆，他们在休息室，调情室。他们正在吃零食。12分02秒，胡萝卜警报。约翰·卡拉辛斯基又在吃那些小胡萝卜了。哦。他又回到了他的健康饮食。嗯，是的，他不再吃爆米花了，他又回到了胡萝卜。迈克尔走进来，说，嘿，你们
guys doing tonight because I've got two tickets to the party in New York you want to go and they're like you know what why not they're like sure together let's do it but then he says all right great but you're going to have to duke it out just let me know who wins and that's when Pam realizes Oh, one of the tickets is for Michael. Mm-hmm. And then she says, as soon as he leaves the room, not it. Smart. Yeah, smart.
今晚要做什么，因为我有两张去纽约派对的票，你们想去吗？他们说，你知道吗，为什么不呢？他们说，当然，一起去吧。但随后他说，好吧，太棒了，但你们得决斗一下，告诉我谁赢了。就在那时帕姆意识到，哦，其中一张票是给迈克尔的。嗯哼。然后她说，当他离开房间时，不是我。聪明。是的，聪明。
So Jim is going to go to this fancy sushi New York launch party with Michael. I bet he's so excited. Now Dwight is on the phone and he's yelling at a client for ordering through the website rather than through him. and Jim and the computer both insist that Dwight seems worried, right? Yep. It's like the computer is like heckling Dwight. He's kind of trolling him. And Dwight writes a very long message at 1301 and binary.
所以吉姆要和迈克尔一起去参加这个高级寿司纽约发布派对。我敢打赌他很兴奋。现在德怀特在打电话，他在对一个客户大喊大叫，因为他们通过网站而不是通过他订购。吉姆和电脑都坚持认为德怀特看起来很担心，对吧？嗯哼。就像电脑在嘲讽德怀特。他在钓鱼他。德怀特在13分01秒用二进制写了一条很长的信息。
And I looked it up on the Internet. I looked it up as well. Okay, what did you find? Well, Pam says that Dwight said, why don't you, 011, 11, 11, 011, 011. Yeah. I ended up on Reddit. So did I. Wow. Oh, boy. Yeah. And someone said that in the way that Pam reads it, it means nothing. Right. But if you add back the zeros that I guess would normally be there in binary code, that it spells F-O. Like F-off. Why don't you F-off? Is it? Did you read the same thing? I read the same thing.
我在互联网上查了。我也查了。好的，你发现了什么？嗯，帕姆说德怀特说，为什么你不，011，11，11，011，011。是的。我最终上了Reddit。我也是。哇。哦，天哪。是的。有人说，按照帕姆读它的方式，它什么意思都没有。没错。但如果你加回我猜在二进制代码中通常会有的零，它拼写为F-O。就像F-off。为什么你不滚开？是吗？你读的是同样的东西吗？我读的是同样的东西。
There was a lot about the two ASCII codes in binary. It was like a little detailed. But according to that Reddit thread that I think we both read, hi Reddit thread folks. Dwight's telling the computer to F off. There you go. Well, now Angela is very angry about some spoons. This is one of my favorite scenes I ever did with Phyllis for the whole run of the show.
关于二进制中的两个ASCII码有很多讨论。它有点详细。但根据我们俩都读过的那个Reddit帖子，嗨，Reddit帖子的朋友们。德怀特是在叫电脑滚开。就是这样。嗯，现在安吉拉对一些勺子非常生气。这是我在整个节目中和菲利斯一起做的我最喜欢的场景之一。
I was texting with Jen. I was like, Jen, I love the scene so much. And she said it was one of her favorite things to write, this whole exchange. And I want you to know we could not stop laughing. Well, I know that, Angela, because you can't see me, but I sat at reception the entire time you were filming this scene. Yes. And we were cracking up. It was so funny.
我正在和简发短信。我说，简，我太喜欢这个场景了。她说这是她最喜欢写的东西之一，整个交流。而且我想让你知道我们笑得停不下来。嗯，我知道，安吉拉，因为你看不见我，但我拍摄这个场景时一直坐在前台。是的。我们笑坏了。太搞笑了。
And it's in the bloopers. And at one point, I was finally holding it together. And then Jen Salada, who's sitting on the sofa by reception, starts laughing. Yeah. And I was like, Jen, and so if you watch the bloopers, you will hear Jen laughing. I'll tell you the line that got you guys every time. I remember it so clearly. It was when Phyllis says the word tone.
而且它在花絮里。有一次，我终于忍住了。然后坐在前台沙发上的简·萨拉达开始笑。是的。我说，简，所以如果你看花絮，你会听到简在笑。我告诉你每次都让你们笑的那句台词。我记得很清楚。那是菲利斯说音调这个词的时候。
She couldn't get through that word. Couldn't say tone. She couldn't say tone without laughing. And then I started anticipating her little. mouth saying tune, and then I couldn't keep it together. Sam, will you play this scene? It's at 13 minutes, 32 seconds. I asked for assorted cutlery and I got back spoons. These are worthless. I want to understand what you're saying, but it's difficult for me when you use that tone. Phyllis, these are spoons. Spoons have rounded tops and are used to scoop things.
她无法说出那个词。无法说出音调。她不笑就说不出音调。然后我开始预料她的小嘴说音调，然后我就忍不住了。萨姆，你能播放这个场景吗？在13分32秒。我要求分类餐具，但我拿回了勺子。这些毫无价值。我想理解你在说什么，但当你用那种语气时，这对我来说很困难。菲利斯，这些是勺子。勺子有圆形的顶部，用于舀东西。
What we need are forks, which have prongs or tiny spears on top. And we need knives, which have blades. Do you understand me now? I have to say, you can't see it when you listen to that clip, but one of my favorite moments is the hand gesture you make when you say blades. You do this little scoppy thing with your hand. You're like, blades. We did a few takes, and in one take, I did forks like this, like prongs with my fingers.
我们需要的是叉子，上面有尖齿或小矛。我们需要刀，它们有刀片。你现在明白我的意思了吗？我必须说，当你听那个片段时你看不见，但我最喜欢的时刻之一是你当你说刀片时做的手势。你用手做了这个小小的舀东西的动作。你就像，刀片。我们拍了几遍，在一次拍摄中，我像这样做了叉子，就像用手指做尖齿。
But that looked too weird. So then I thought I'll only do one hand gesture and I'll save it for the knife. So good. And my cheerleaders out there, you know that. You know blades, blades, candlesticks. Come on. Wait, that's actually a hand gesture in cheerleading for a blade. That's blade.
但这看起来太奇怪了。所以我认为我只会做一个手势，我会把它留给刀。太棒了。还有我的啦啦队长们，你们知道那个。你们知道刀片，刀片，烛台。来吧。等等，那实际上是啦啦队里的一个手势，刀片。那是刀片。
Okay. Yeah, candlesticks. Candlestick is a fist. Why did these need special names? I don't know. I don't know. It was cheerleading camp. And who even knows if it's universal?
好的。是的，烛台。烛台是一个拳头。为什么这些需要特殊的名字？我不知道。我不知道。那是啦啦队训练营。谁知道它是不是通用的？
Maybe it was just my cheerleading camp. Are there any more? I'm dying to know. Well, you know jazz hands. Jazz hands I get. That's a whole thing. I mean, you have to like put all your fingers out and kind of like flutter your hands. I mean, that makes sense to me.
也许那只是我的啦啦队训练营。还有更多吗？我渴望知道。嗯，你知道爵士手。爵士手我懂。那是一整套东西。我是说，你必须把所有的手指伸出来，有点像挥动你的手。我是说，这对我来说有意义。
And then this is candlesticks. Candlesticks is fists. And then blades. Blades is just your palms up. Yeah, like what I did in the scene. Yeah. All right. Okay.
然后这是烛台。烛台是拳头。然后是刀片。刀片只是你的手掌向上。是的，就像我在场景里做的那样。是的。好吧。好的。
So like when you're doing cheerleading camp and you're choreographing your cheer, in your head are you thinking like, Blade, Blade, Jazz Hands, Candlesticks! Blade, Blade! Yes. And you're like, ready. Okay. Blade. Candlestick.
所以就像你在啦啦队训练营，你在编排你的欢呼时，你在脑子里想的是，刀片，刀片，爵士手，烛台！刀片，刀片！是的。你就像，准备好了。好的。刀片。烛台。
Candlestick. Okay. Blade. Got it. We're doing this and no one can see us. No one can see us, but I am enjoying it immensely. Okay. Okay.
烛台。好的。刀片。明白了。我们在做这个，没人能看见我们。没人能看见我们，但我非常享受它。好的。好的。
This is another thing Angela did in high school, everyone, also a cheerleader. In addition to all of the musical instruments and sports that she played. Well, I was the mascot for football. And the mascot. What's the mascot? Did you sleep? I cheered for basketball. No, but I told you my mom's theory is keep them busy.
这是安吉拉高中时做的另一件事，大家，也是一名啦啦队长。除了她演奏的所有乐器和运动之外。嗯，我是足球队的吉祥物。还有吉祥物。什么是吉祥物？你睡了吗？我为篮球欢呼。不，但我告诉过你我妈妈的理论是让他们忙起来。
They stay out of trouble. Yeah. And also nothing good. happens after midnight. Nothing good happens after midnight. Well, listen, Daryl is about to deliver some paper to Kelly. And there's some flirty flirt that happens in that annex. Well, Dwight is so furious that Kelly ordered off the website. He's like, do you know what this means? And he's yelling at her. And Darrell's like, step off. Well, listen, she explains, it's really cute. You take the paper and you put it in a little shopping basket and it makes a cute little sound.
他们就不会惹麻烦。是的。而且午夜过后没有好事发生。午夜过后没有好事发生。嗯，听着，达里尔正要给凯利送一些纸。附件里发生了一些调情。嗯，德怀特非常愤怒，因为凯利在网站上订购。他说，你知道这意味着什么吗？他在对她大喊大叫。达里尔说，退后。嗯，听着，她解释说，这真的很可爱。你拿纸，把它放在一个小购物篮里，它会发出可爱的声音。
This is all Kelly could ever hope for. Yeah. Online shopping. Like she has arrived. But Darrell comes to her defense, like you said. And suddenly she's not missing Ryan so much, is she? There's a little moment here. Yeah.
这是凯利所能希望的一切。是的。网上购物。就像她到了。但达里尔站出来为她辩护，就像你说的。突然间她没那么想念瑞安了，不是吗？这里有一个小瞬间。是的。
Mm-hmm. So now we're going to move into some sabotage. Did you say sandwich? Dwight gets out this little red box. He unlocks a lot of things and then he unlocks this little box. And he explains that when he left Staples, he took some of the Staples leads as a souvenir. He doesn't know why he did it. But maybe it was to use them one day and he's going to use them today.
嗯。现在我们要进入一些破坏活动了。你说三明治？德怀特拿出了那个红色的小盒子。他解锁了很多东西，然后解锁了这个小盒子。他解释说，当他离开史泰博时，他拿走了一些史泰博的销售线索作为纪念品。他不知道自己为什么要这么做。但也许是为了有一天能用上，而他今天就要用上它们了。
Yeah, he has got to beat the computer. In his mind, if he beats the computer, he wins Angela back. I think that's where his rationale is. Yes, exactly. And it's working. He calls up and they're like, how did you get this number? And he's like, it's not important.
是的，他必须打败电脑。在他看来，如果他打败了电脑，他就能赢回安吉拉。我想这就是他的逻辑。是的，没错。而且这招奏效了。他打过去，对方问，你是怎么得到这个号码的？他说，这不重要。
But do you want to save money on paper? And they clearly say yes because he starts logging all of these sales. And it's a very big deal. It's a big, big deal. And while this is happening, Michael and Jim are getting ready to leave for the party. Michael sort of does this sing-songy and tells everyone that he'll be back tomorrow, you know, the way he does his little sing-talky thing. Yep. And he's leaving in Jim's car. In Jim's car. And he tells everyone they can leave early. And Angel's like, no, they can't. I've
但你想在纸张上省钱吗？他们显然说了愿意，因为他开始记录所有这些销售额。这是一件大事。非常非常大的事。就在这发生的同时，迈克尔和吉姆正准备出发去参加派对。迈克尔用那种唱歌般的语调告诉大家他明天会回来，你知道，就是他那种小小的唱谈方式。没错。他要坐吉姆的车走。坐吉姆的车。他告诉大家他们可以早点下班。安吉拉说，不，他们不能。我已经
been planning a party for weeks. Yeah. He can't leave early. And then he makes fun of her. And he's like, you must be this tall or you may not ride the roller coaster. Shorty joke number three. That's my favorite one. That was my favorite. Jen is like, Angela, I do not remember writing those. I don't think they were in the script. And I think Steve was just having fun.
计划派对好几周了。是的。他不能早走。然后他取笑她。他说，你必须长到这么高才能坐过山车。第三个矮子笑话。那是我最喜欢的一个。那也是我最喜欢的。珍娜说，安吉拉，我不记得写过那些台词。我觉得剧本里没有。我想史蒂夫只是在自娱自乐。
Well, after Michael and Jim leave, the competition is over and Dwight wins. He beats the computer. Like you said, Angela, he really does not get the attention he deserves from this company. He beat a computer. Yeah. I mean, yes, he had to use.
好吧，在迈克尔和吉姆离开后，比赛结束了，德怀特赢了。他打败了电脑。就像你说的，安吉拉，他在这家公司确实没有得到他应得的关注。他打败了一台电脑。是的。我是说，是的，他不得不使用
the stolen leads, but he beats a computer. He beat the computer, Andy starts blowing this bearhorn like crazy, and Angela is not having it. She's just like, just stop it. Well, when I watched this episode with Lee, at the end of it, he said, I have one question. Did that bearhorn really make a sound? Or did they put that in in post? Okay, well, here is my memory of this particular moment. Now, I don't know about the other moments where it went off, but in this moment where I walk by, I was just supposed to walk by and sort of like glare at them and cruise on past. And that whole thing where I'm like, give me that, give it. That was all improvised because Andy, well, Ed is just kind of having fun with that thing. He's like, he's doing a dance.
那些偷来的线索，但他打败了电脑。他打败了电脑，安迪开始疯狂地吹那个气喇叭，安吉拉受不了了。她只是说，停下。好吧，当我和李看这一集时，在结尾，他说，我有一个问题。那个气喇叭真的发出了声音吗？还是后期加进去的？好吧，这是我对这一特定时刻的记忆。现在，我不知道它响起的其他时刻，但在我走过去的那一刻，我本来只是要走过去，瞪他们一眼然后走开。而我那种说“给我，给我”的动作，全是即兴发挥的，因为安迪，嗯，埃德只是在玩那个东西。他在跳舞。
And so I had to grab at it a few times to get it. So I just sort of improvised all of that. And I can tell you he was really shooting it off in that moment. I told Lee, my memory is that they gave Ed a bear horn and Ed had a great time with it. Yeah. I remember it going off constantly. This reminded me of when they gave Rain the keyboard in the Dundies. Yes. Do not give these guys things that make sounds.
所以我不得不抓了几次才抢过来。所以我只是即兴发挥了所有这些动作。我可以告诉你，那一刻他确实是在吹那个喇叭。我告诉李，我的记忆是他们给了埃德一个气喇叭，埃德玩得很开心。是的。我记得它一直在响。这让我想起他们在《邓迪奖》里给雷恩键盘的时候。是的。不要给这些家伙会发出声音的东西。
No. No props that make noises. They cannot stop using them. It was really funny. So, yeah, I was just supposed to walk by and just kind of grab it and give him a look. And that's like me legitimately trying to grab it out of Ed's hand. Like, give it here. Well, now we cut to the car where Michael and Jim are driving to New York City.
不。不要给会发出噪音的道具。他们停不下来。这真的很有趣。所以，是的，我本来只是要走过去，顺手抢过来，瞪他一眼。那真的是我在努力从埃德手里抢过来。就像，给我。好吧，现在镜头切到迈克尔和吉姆开车去纽约市的路上。
And I noted something in this scene. Was it when Michael blew a kiss to Pennsylvania? Well, he blew a kiss one for him and one for Jan. I know. I thought it was the cutest thing. My kids, whenever we leave a city, say goodbye to the city. If we're driving. Yeah, we wave goodbye. Like if we're driving to the beach or up to the mountains, they're like, goodbye, Los Angeles. Goodbye, beach. And to me, it was this very sweet, childlike moment of Michael. Well, I'll say the moment that struck me in the car was when Michael says to Jim, you should come over for dinner on Friday night. oh girl oh girl i was like ding ding ding it's coming dinner party is coming and also that deleted scene you talked about where michael and jan were on the phone and she's like we should make a roast this friday all of these things i feel like that's planting a seed for her also boko is that how you say it her her five hour yeah with no with no snacks out who does that who does that who doesn't
我注意到了这一幕中的一些东西。是迈克尔向宾夕法尼亚州飞吻的时候吗？嗯，他飞了一个吻，一个给自己，一个给珍。我知道。我觉得这是最可爱的事情。我的孩子们，每当我们离开一个城市，都会跟城市说再见。如果我们是在开车的话。是的，我们会挥手告别。就像如果我们开车去海滩或山上，他们会说，再见，洛杉矶。再见，海滩。对我来说，这是迈克尔非常甜蜜、孩子气的一刻。好吧，我要说在车里让我印象深刻的时刻是迈克尔对吉姆说，你应该周五晚上来吃晚饭。哦天哪，哦天哪，我当时想，叮叮叮，要来了，晚宴派对要来了。还有你提到的那个被删减的片段，迈克尔和珍在电话里，她说，我们这个周五应该做个烤肉，我觉得所有这些都在为她做铺垫。还有博科，是这么说的吗？她的五小时，是的，没有零食，谁会那样做？谁会那样做？谁不会
doesn't offer a cheese plate. We'll discuss later. We will get there. We will have a lot of discussion about it. But I felt like this planted the seed, this idea that Michael was going to want Jim and Pam to come over for dinner. Michael has also purchased a gift for Ryan. He wanted to get Ryan, oh, the places you'll go by Dr. Seuss.
不提供奶酪拼盘。我们稍后再讨论。我们会谈到的。我们会对此进行很多讨论。但我感觉这埋下了伏笔，迈克尔想要吉姆和帕姆来吃晚饭的想法。迈克尔还给瑞安买了一份礼物。他想买苏斯博士的《噢，你要去的地方》。
But it wasn't available. So he got green eggs and ham. It's kind of the same thing, he says. And what is Ryan going to think? when he opens this, and it's green eggs and ham. I don't know. Also, oh, the places you will go is such a personal message to someone. And again, Michael doesn't have this kind of relationship with Ryan, but is convinced he does.
但没货了。所以他买了《绿鸡蛋和火腿》。他说，这差不多是一回事。瑞安打开这个，发现是《绿鸡蛋和火腿》，他会怎么想？我不知道。还有，《噢，你要去的地方》对某人来说是一条非常私人的信息。再说一次，迈克尔和瑞安并没有那种关系，但他坚信他们有。
Yeah, and also, hasn't Ryan already gone to the places he'll go? Well, there's that. I don't know. Well, finally on this drive, Jim asks Michael for the exact address of, the party and Michael says it's at a bar called chat room and there's a password to get in. And Jim's like, Michael, you were invited to the satellite party. That's our party. Well, first, he just pulls the car over. Yeah. As soon as he hears this, he's like, I don't even need to hear anymore. He just starts slowing the car down and he's going to do a Ui. He's like Michael.
是的，而且，瑞安不是已经去过他要去的地方了吗？嗯，确实。我不知道。好吧，最后在这次车程中，吉姆问迈克尔派对的确切地址，迈克尔说是在一个叫“聊天室”的酒吧，进去需要密码。吉姆说，迈克尔，你被邀请参加的是卫星派对。那是我们的派对。好吧，首先，他直接把车停下了。是的。他一听到这个，就说，我不需要再听了。他开始减速，准备掉头。他说，迈克尔。
Yeah. And Michael is on the phone to Ryan. He's like, what do you? mean, I'm already in the city. Part of the city. I'm in the city. How could you do this? He's so upset. He feels so rejected. Yeah. And he throws the book out the window. Yeah. He's not going to give that book to Ryan anymore. And now Michael is going to have to go back and celebrate this launch with the rest of the folks in the conference room. The losers at the satellite party. And Dwight is convinced that winning and beating the computer that Angela's going to be impressed, it's going to be the thing that turns the tide, she's going to want him back, and she is not impressed. In fact, she's annoyed by it. And she has a talking head where she's like, how do you tell someone it's over?
是的。迈克尔正在和瑞安通电话。他说，你什么意思？我已经进城了。城里的一部分。我在城里。你怎么能这样？他非常难过。他感到被拒绝了。是的。他把书扔出了窗外。是的。他不再打算把那本书给瑞安了。现在迈克尔不得不回去和会议室里的其他人一起庆祝这次发布会。卫星派对上的失败者们。德怀特坚信，赢了比赛并打败电脑，安吉拉会印象深刻，这将是扭转局面的关键，她会想让他回来，但她一点也不觉得印象深刻。事实上，她对此感到厌烦。她有一个采访镜头，她说，你怎么告诉别人结束了？
You send them a notarized letter, right? But what if your ex is your notary? Yeah. It's really perplexing. And she makes a big to-do of going up to front reception and telling Pam that she would very much like to date a man. And if Pam could please set her up. And she says it loud enough for Dwight to hear. And then Dwight is just, he's just brokenhearted and Pam sees it.
你寄给他们一封公证过的信，对吧？但如果你的前任就是你的公证人呢？是的。这真的很令人困惑。她大张旗鼓地走到前台，告诉帕姆她非常想和一个男人约会。如果帕姆能帮她安排一下。她说话的声音大到足以让德怀特听到。然后德怀特心碎了，帕姆看到了。
And so in this way that we have these little moments with Pam and Dwight, Pam sends him a little direct message as the computer congratulating him on his win and telling him he is the superior being. But it doesn't help much. It doesn't. Dwight's heartbroken. Yeah. It's heartbroken. And that is the first part of launch party, part one. Yes. Next week, we're going to see Angelus Party in the conference room. And Michael is going to take the pizza delivery guy hostage. Michael's going to be Michael. Michael's going to be Michael. Michael's going to be in rare form. And Andy is going to make a play for Angela. Yeah. Yeah. Good stuff next week. There's one runner in deleted scenes. Before we go, I wanted to tell you about Jenna. Because I think you really should watch it. You would get a kick out of it. You personally, Jenna Fisher, love the character Toby. You love Toby. And there is a Toby runner where he is taking an online, like, driving driver's school course or something. And there's a series of scenes where we find out that
所以，在我们和帕姆与德怀特有这些小互动的方式中，帕姆通过电脑给他发了一条直接消息，祝贺他获胜，并告诉他他是优越的存在。但这没多大帮助。确实没有。德怀特心碎了。是的。心碎了。这就是《发布会派对》第一部分。是的。下周，我们将看到安吉拉在会议室举办的派对。迈克尔会把送披萨的人扣为人质。迈克尔就是迈克尔。迈克尔就是迈克尔。迈克尔会表现得非常反常。安迪会试图追求安吉拉。是的。是的。下周有好戏看。有一个被删减的片段。在我们走之前，我想告诉你关于珍娜的事。因为我觉得你真的应该看看。你会喜欢的。你个人，珍娜·费舍尔，喜欢托比这个角色。你喜欢托比。有一个关于托比的片段，他正在参加一个在线驾驶学校课程之类的。有一系列场景，我们发现
Toby is a horrible driver. This is such a random runner. I know. It's not related to anything else. And Oscar has a great talking head, talking about what it's like riding in a car with Toby. Anyway, apparently Toby is a horrible driver. And it just was so delightful. It made me laugh. They probably created that for Paul so that he didn't have to be in any of the main scenes. They created a reason that his character was off doing something independently so he could actually be in the writer's room. They would do that a lot. Yeah. So he was through this whole episode, Toby is taking this online driver's school course and we find out what a crappy driver he is.
托比是个糟糕的司机。这是一个非常随机的片段。我知道。它和其他任何东西都没有关系。奥斯卡有一个很棒的采访镜头，谈论和托比一起坐车是什么感觉。总之，显然托比是个糟糕的司机。这太令人愉快了。它让我笑了。他们可能是为了保罗才创作了这个片段，这样他就不必出现在任何主要场景中。他们创造了一个理由，让他的角色在外面独立做某事，这样他实际上可以待在编剧室里。他们经常这样做。是的。所以在他这一整集中，托比都在参加这个在线驾驶学校课程，我们发现他是个多么糟糕的司机。
I love it. Well, guys, that was lunch party, part one. We'll be back next week with part to yeah look out denise stems look out i don't think that angela's going to win this one i'm sorry i don't know i hate to tell you buffalo's going to show you up all right we'll see you next week bye you guys thank you for listening to office ladies second drink this episode was initially created in collaboration with earwolf office ladies is a presentation of odyssey and is pretty by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Juerkins, and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent.
我喜欢它。好吧，伙计们，这就是《发布会派对》第一部分。我们下周会带着第二部分回来。是的，小心丹尼斯·斯泰姆斯，小心，我不认为安吉拉会赢这一局，抱歉，我不知道，我不想告诉你，布法罗会让你出丑的。好吧，我们下周见。再见，伙计们，感谢收听《办公室女士》第二杯。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·尤尔金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。